now survival is just the rules have
changed man you're used to being a sigma
male man no it's hard they got to pay
bills [ __ ] man i got me sigma mail while
i pay the bills [ __ ] that
don't pay your bills
hi everyone welcome to another episode
of the trash taste podcast i'm joey and
i'm with the boys hello was that the
intro yeah man intro joey intros have
really gone downhill in the past yeah
man maybe like salty salmon spices or
whatever the [ __ ] what are the [ __ ]
youtube comments
i like the old intros better i like the
old studio better you know i remember
when joey put effort into his intros
about trash taste yeah right
remember when like half of my intros
would get the episodes demonstrated it's
so annoying they lost like thousands of
dollars joey one of those couldn't
resist being constructed
australian yeah
i can't help them i have to fight the
ocean to say all the bad words can you
guys tell i'm absolutely ripped today i
went to the gym the first time in two
months i was about oh my what i'm
absolutely pumped right first time in
two months first time two months my body
is dying so you signed up to the new gym
at your new place i did i did
and it's it's different and the
etiquette is slightly different so it
kind of threw me off wait did you sign
up by yourself
uh yeah yeah it's impossible
i don't believe you i was trying to i
don't believe you i shouldn't remember
how i did it and it was confusing
because it was all blur
he was asking dave and i was like yes
well that's just every interaction i
have with a japanese person in japan
they ask me something and i just say yes
here's how good my japanese has gotten
to this point now yeah i can it's kind
of like i'm i'm kind of filling in the
blanks
it kind of feels like you're doing one
of those mario party mini games where
you you see a part of the sequence and
you're like i think i know where the
sequence is going it's like going into a
mario party game without looking at the
controls right it's like a hundred
percent i think i think this is out so
now now i i'm getting to the point where
i'm
i'm i'm accustomed to
the normal flow of signing up to things
so i kind of understand what they're
saying
and i understood most of what was told
of me and a lot of it was just like hey
read this and i'm like oh so it's just
really weird when they pulled the knife
out and made me science selling my blood
you know i was like oh that's you know i
guess that's true the rectal exam was a
bit weird
[Music]
is it
i don't know we fact check that
can we fight check them out listen when
i went in there it looked american yeah
yeah
they all do because all the gyms used
for white people to uh advertise yeah
advertise their gym
at the front of our old gym there was
like it was like five banners of just
like really attractive white guys
i've never seen a japanese person be
advertised on a gym before it is weird
having japanese just white people is
like the standard it's like i'm like i
think it's my i think it might just be
because like going to the gym in this
country is like a [ __ ] luxury because
of how expensive that was no it's not
just that who the [ __ ] what japanese
person has time to go to a gym that's
true also most of it most often is
people are in shape right and the people
that aren't in shape i don't think they
care about being in shape no yeah they
have like they're like i i've got
everything i need in my life yeah yeah
yeah you'll be in shape uh i've got my
my seven levels like why why are you
working out i wasn't just like naturally
in [ __ ]
[ __ ] you
how did you get fat how did
basically yeah pretty much uh yeah i
signed up and i don't know i i i mean
i'm pretty yeah like i said i'm pretty
sure anytime fit is american we had a
fact check and it was an american yeah i
just assumed it was america
that sounds american like joyfit 24 yeah
that's not [ __ ] american yeah that
sounds japanese that sounds like what a
japanese people think american people
think of gyms yeah yes you're joyful in
your your fears and it's over 24 hours
there you go so it's a joy i mean
anytime fitness isn't much better i
signed up to it
uh didn't really know what the [ __ ] was
going on they took my picture i got the
key thing i signed my life away they
asked for my card yeah it worked out so
i i believe i'm signed up so
that's good i i walked in yesterday and
nobody stopped me
one thing i've noticed uh about moving
is like you know having to cancel
memberships and having to cancel stuff
is like ten times easier than signing up
to something yeah
it's the opposite in the west right yeah
yeah yeah cause like i i was dreading
having to cancel my gym membership
because i remember when we signed up to
a gym membership it took like 45 minutes
to an hour of just reading forms so i
was just like so me and cindy had to go
cancel out gym membership and we said
one word which was just like we would
like to cancel our membership and we had
to find one piece of paper yeah it took
five minutes take five why can't signing
up be that easy yeah why don't you like
no leaving fees just like yeah use the
gym until like the end of the month like
it's like it's like everything you're
not supposed to do as a business right
it's like why it's like i love how how
hesitant they are to sign you up to you
it's like are you sure
you want to give us money every month
yeah yeah that's why i'm [ __ ] here
just let me get in for christ's sake
exactly the moment you leave they're
like oh thank god all right here you go
take it get the [ __ ] out
like i had to change over my internet as
well that was
surprisingly painless because they were
like no worries did you want to cancel
your internet or did you want to move to
a new place and i'm just like it's it is
which one's easier not like it's both
the same it's just one trap yeah yeah
yeah
yeah exactly it's just like yeah where's
the catch where's the camera but then
why is it like such pulling teeth when
you're like signing up for like water or
gas at the new places like are you sure
you want water in your place it's like
yes please thank you like i only just
okay so i moved to our current place
like what five almost six months ago
right and i only just finished
finalizing my water stuff
really yeah because like for some reason
because i got like a new bank account
and wither came a new card and for some
reason they didn't allow me to use my
new bank account
because it's not under the same name or
some kind of well you said you said the
b word bank
in japan
my previous place and it was pretty
painless right so i was like okay i mean
you know it's just changing a bank
account how hard could it be famous last
question how hard could it be nothing
with the word bank in japan is ever easy
but what i don't understand right is
that okay so i signed up and i'm like
okay i want to change to my new bank
because like you know my money situation
has changed in this new place and they
were like sure no worries we'll send you
a form you can fill out all your
information and then mail it back to us
all right email is also a thing but
anyway so they so so i think about a
month after that phone call finally the
form comes in i was like
all right i don't know why this took a
month to send out but sure
fill it in in five minutes send it off
two months later i get a phone call and
they say
uh so your bank is not
able to be used oh my god i'm like
ciao marty
you could have told me that on the phone
three months ago
why is it now after all this like
waiting and sending out a form that
you're finally like
jk
they're gonna call you up and be like
yeah by the way the rate of inflation
has changed so significantly in the past
two months
all over again yeah right have you been
paying for water since then so before it
just used to be like a bank transfer
like every month like automatically but
since then i've had to like get the form
they mail you the form that says the
amount and then i have to go to the uh
family mart or the yeah
and do it by cash yeah which just like
[ __ ] me up because sometimes i don't
check my mail every day and then there
was one month where i almost like got my
water stopped oh my god because they
just straight up didn't send me my form
and i'm like and then they call me and
they're like uh so you haven't paid for
your thing i'm like i haven't given me
the [ __ ] what am i supposed to do
am i supposed to be like am i supposed
to go to my life
am i supposed to go to the company being
like uh sorry i don't have the form but
like trust me
i owe you guys this i i have to pay i
have to give you this money i've
realized right that when i first moved
here i thought oh my god i can pay my
bills at the the local company yeah this
is amazing this is great yeah now i
realize it's just to avoid banks yeah
it's just like this whole car this
country has set up a system where the
banks just don't need to do anything but
they still have to have all your money
yeah basically
yeah and they give you like what is it
like 0.001
interest or something like that the
interest gets wiped out by every every
time you want to take out money that's
true
like you you basically there's less
interest than the p the the fees you pay
for like any service yeah japan is the
only country where like hiding your
money under your mattress might be a
better investment than putting it into a
bank honestly
it's probably safer
don't spend money in the country like
people just don't no they don't yeah so
they're like why would we give you
interest if people are going to keep
money in their bank
weirdly is like a weird like
money-saving mentality in this country
even for people who have the money to
spend so yeah apparently the one of the
reasons why they didn't want to give
more money as people during the peak
pandemic is because uh people just don't
spend the money so they would just be
giving money that wouldn't help
stimulate the economy yeah cause people
wouldn't go out even if you gave them a
thousand bucks most people would just
gonna keep it right right i'm not gonna
like i would that's not surprising
because like domestic tourism is massive
here it's just a massive but it's from
here but it is right it's like 90 of the
economy yeah exactly right
from what i understand of the domestic
tourism here it is like a massive luxury
yeah most people can't afford to go from
what i understand and also don't have
the time
yeah i think i think the biggest
resource for any japanese person
especially working is time yeah i don't
have time to do anything if you ever go
to a ryokan right if you stay there for
two nights i guarantee you're probably
like one out of 100 people who are
staying there for more than one night oh
yeah everyone leaves the next day always
i've noticed that like if i go and park
my car it's full next day empty the car
park yeah at like two o'clock because no
one's checking in until like four yeah
and i'm the only [ __ ] who apparently
stayed even though it makes more sense
to have a hotel room for these two days
because you at least get one full day of
the room yeah that never made sense to
me because how can you enjoy the day
because that means you spend
most ryokan you can't check until check
in until three or four and they won't
let you check in early as well yeah even
if there's space even if they're spaced
with japanese hotels and it's not just
ryokans hotels as well even if they have
space in the hotel you still can't check
in until the check in time i feel that
the problem though is that like the the
main demographic that goes to your cars
for one night is usually like retirees
yeah right
itself is the exploring right but you
know what sucks like is the fact that
you don't even get like a full 24 hours
when you buy one night yeah that's
that's why i in my head i'm like this is
so inefficient that is why like you
should never ever like even if you stay
in like let's say you're staying in
kyoto right you should you should never
change hotel every night because you're
just wasting yeah wasting time wasting
uh wasting time that you could have in
the hotel room yeah you get the
breakfast as well or whatever i don't
know you you know carrying your bags
around pain in the ass yeah yeah plus
plus like when i'm on a holiday when i'm
staying in a hotel or ryokan when i want
to relax
i don't want to think about what time i
need to wake up the morning after that's
true right i want at least one day when
i'm just like if i want to lie in i can
lie in you know i want to crack some
beers open with the boys i want to know
maybe lie until like 10 o'clock you know
whatever yeah but in ryokans you have to
wake up at eight because most people are
only staying there for one night and you
know they they have to wake up early to
check out yeah
on japan's side of things like having to
sleep or getting to sleep in is like the
privileged way of enjoying it's like wow
you would stay here for more than one
night what the [ __ ] you privileged [ __ ]
i uh
was uh i can't remember when i went to
ryokan but i went to one yeah and
i remember i was just i loved it but
then i was absolutely appalled that they
made us check out at 9 00 am yeah
really is this privilege or i don't know
if this is my privilege i've never seen
that before like 9am not 9am bro give me
a chance to like brush my teeth i don't
even wake up at night holy [ __ ] i'm
trying to relax out here you have to
check out at 9am and i guarantee like
earliest check-in is like four yeah
that's the thing it's like what are you
cleaning for so long well not surely
this cannot take that long
the one thing that i love about like
american hotels is that whenever i've
always asked for late checkout they've
always given it to me like if it's like
an hour extra like they always chill
about it like sometimes they've charged
me like 20 30 bucks extra but japanese
hotel i remember one time i said in a
hotel room um in niigata yeah and the
hotel room itself was ninety dollars
for an extra hour
right with 70 dollars
just for one extra hour to stay in the
room past 11. right and i was like i was
like
did i hear that correct can you can you
say that again like much please like 70
the room was 90. how does that make any
sense
tell me like [ __ ] me down because
because because i think to them anything
past that time limit is an extra day no
it's it's to them they're offering late
check out without offering late check
out you know what i mean
it's like we got late check out but it's
not really late check out what it is
late check it out
nothing's late about it was empty as
well it was like like pete corona there
was nobody staying here why were you
trying to swindle me well yeah they're
fighting for their life man they need
that extra money
because no one's staying there they're
like oh let's charge this guy 70 bucks
i'll give you i'll i know i know it's
not culture i'll tip you man just leave
me alone don't charge me 70 bucks for
this [ __ ] what do i need to do
it's weird though because like most like
high end yokans especially they're
usually quite lenient with uh you know
light checkouts and stuff like we just
uh myself and aki and a few others just
came back from this yamanashi yeah and
like they said the checkout was like 9
30. yeah we were there till like 11 00
and then we're like yeah you're good
it's like okay then why are you kicking
us out at 9 30 if that's the case
did you ask them for late check out or
did were they just like no they were
like no they said the night before they
were like oh yeah so it's 9 30 check out
is that okay and we were like uh we
might be here for longer is that okay
and they were like okay
i'm like then why did you tell me that
was the checkout time like what the [ __ ]
maybe just most japanese people just
don't ask
yeah most japanese people like those are
the rules we must follow their rules
i know it's just wrong they're like
really anal about getting their if it
says 12. they are so paranoid about
checking out after like one minute after
twelve years yeah yeah yeah yeah it's
because yeah i feel just that's just
like japanese culture in general though
like we're very strict on time like yeah
every time because nobody has it here
but hotels it's like i don't want to be
like fighting for my life 10 minutes
before check out like yeah just i'll
i'll i'll come i'll come 20 minutes
after no one's gonna care no one's like
give your
i'm trying to enjoy this bathtub you
gave me you know what i mean like come
on
it's like how can you enjoy it when
you're stressed about time
and i guess that's why i'm so
like confused as to why people stay in
ryokans for like one night because i
feel like you need a minimum of two
nights to enjoy the experience
three nights if you really just want a
relaxing weekend or whatever that's
that's that's real privilege in japan
yeah like i've never heard of anyone's
like a japanese person staying at a
dilcon for more than one night because
to them it's like because to them that
one night is probably the equivalent to
like a week to something yeah you know
it's like oh my god finally like a night
where i'm not working and just get to
like do whatever the [ __ ] because
another thing about ryokans is that
there's like they really pressure you to
go to breakfast and
i'm already a breakfast guy
especially not a ryokan breakfast guy
you know like i don't need a
three-course meal for breakfast which is
basically what those breakfasts are
american breakfasts think they're big oh
no
yokan kaiseki breakfast makes american
breakfast look [ __ ] tiny yeah death
by a thousand bites bro like they just
they keep giving you tiny pieces and
they keep coming and they keep and they
won't stop and you know you know it's
over when they finally ask like do you
want some tea or coffee but by that
point you're already dead yeah they've
already stuffed you yeah you've stopped
i actually felt bad when uh everyone got
mad at you about the breakfast tweet in
your uh in your hotel because it was it
was like one of the few times i'm like
i agree with connor
i'm just like yeah yeah i you don't need
that much food for breakfast you really
don't
i just you know i i i'm a simple man for
breakfast i don't really eat it i tend
to eat it if i've got something big
about to happen yeah yeah you know the
cycling special all right yeah i'll have
some breakfast because that's just a
wise choice yeah you have to exercise
but if i'm not exercising i'm not eating
breakfast yeah give me a cereal bar at
most right i'm i'm not really big on it
i'd rather have a nicer lunch yeah
i'm not hungry when i wake up no no i
don't know how people can just wake up
and go like yeah i feel like a buffet
yeah no because like if i have a big
breakfast uh which i'm i've rarely
enjoyed the big breakfast because i'm
not hungry for breakfast yeah like that
means i'm just not gonna eat lunch or
that means i'm just gonna get hungry for
dinner at this really weird time yeah
which is like a bit early for dinner but
like too late for lunch right it like
[ __ ] up my eating schedule the worst is
being you know when you like
you're kind of hungry and you wake up
because maybe you didn't eat too much
the night before yeah and then like it
really you really start to get hungry at
like 11. that's the worst time because
you're like [ __ ] it's too early for
lunch but yeah i'm holding out but i
don't want breakfast
for breakfast i'm holding out here for
my goddamn life
and uh
oh my god i just i think i think what it
is is that i
i hate the feeling of like having a food
coma before 12 p.m yeah yeah it's like
because you you're just tired
in the morning and i'm like i don't want
that do you down a bunch of water when
you wake up yes i mean i'm normally full
from that as well i i drink something
you drink like a lot of [ __ ] i drink
i drink a lot of water
like 500 milliliters of water yeah yeah
i i drink at least like minimum two or
three hours yeah i also just want to get
stuck in with my day like if i need a
shower i want to do that i go start
working right i just kind of want to i
kind of want to get on with my day i
don't know i don't really want to sit
around [ __ ] around and just eat
something yeah like like having having
like a fry up that that means something
that means it's like a special occasion
you know it's like i can't have a fry up
every day i don't even recommend you
have a frying pan but like even cereal
even just cereal to me is just that's a
big meal for breakfast yeah to me like i
a lot of people say breakfast is the
most important meal of the day um i
don't know how accurate that is no
that's the [ __ ] cereal company's life
the cereal companies have tricked us
making us think that these [ __ ] carb
monstrosities are necessary i do not
need corn flakes when i wake up
[ __ ] the most i'll eat for
breakfast is a single banana
like i'll have this
they're putting chemicals in the
cornflakes to turn you gay
so they've got the frogs that's right
frosties only many frosties look the
most i have for breakfast is like a
banana and that's like oh yeah yeah
that's that's that's me that's me done
yeah
yeah
i know the fruit companies aren't trying
to convince me to freak out
big big fruit companies farming
corporations
well no because it's like the whole
[ __ ] uh the whole uh you know the
whole the whole chart [ __ ] came from
the the pyramid of what you should eat
in your day and you should eat this much
better oh yeah and it's just complete
nonsense the food pyramid scheme well
yeah and like the whole idea of that you
need to eat these uh corn flakes which
offers no nutritional value in the
morning and stuff like that yeah like
wheat was at the bottom right yeah it's
like no it's like no it's not it was it
was all pioneered by these uh you know
companies but way back that yeah they
had an agenda to promote their stuff
yeah and of course if if if you're the
kellogg's team you're gonna and you you
have your scientific research team the
conference you're gonna be like hey
hey uh kellogg's scientific team could
you maybe
maybe you know i'm not saying to excuse
the results but like if there was some
kind of correlation that said that calyx
is good for breakfast yeah really help
us out here that would i'm not i'm not
saying you should convince the world
that fruit loops is healthy or anything
you know just like just maybe like a
hint at it
because we
that contract for five years is you know
not gonna be necessary if no one's
buying corn flakes so uh uh you know i
yeah
i i don't know what age i just was like
no more cereal for me i won't do it i
don't really ever eat cereal anymore i
wasn't i wasn't brought up in a cereal
household so i never got the craving of
it and there's a toast house yeah and
not like cereal to me always tastes like
a sweet like a dessert what else do you
go for it depends what you have i will
say and i've just shot on cereal for
like five minutes yeah but i do like i
do like brand flakes i really really
like i love brands yeah they're good but
like i remember one time
one time as a kid when i discovered
brown flakes i thought these are so good
that i just will keep eating them all
day yeah so i had the whole box in one
day
and uh that was me and coco puffs yeah
and uh yeah but brown flakes is like
yeah fiber on crack
oh lord my toilet activity that day yeah
i was
i i imagined they they had the they were
filming lord of the rings mordor scenes
out of my my bathroom than that yeah it
was [ __ ] horrible i was nothing
so much pain there's nothing worse than
an overly fibrous [ __ ] oh my god i was i
was scared i was genuinely scared i was
like 12 years old and i was like why do
they make them taste so good yeah i've
got man flakes oh my god yeah i used to
have a [ __ ] horrible diet when i was
little but everyone does they your
parents are like yes go on eat those
gummies that were made in the [ __ ]
ninja turtles sewer yeah cause like
cause like my my parents had no
retaliation on giving me my sister like
cocoa puffs and like uh fruit loops and
like yeah nutrigrain and all the [ __ ]
like sugary cereals i understand you
know now when you're a parent that it's
it it seems very difficult because
you're already
kind of struggling just to get by the
last thing you want to do is start like
comparing cocoa puffs with you know it
it shuts the kid out for 10 minutes give
him the [ __ ] cocoa puffs right yeah
but then later on you're like all right
maybe i shouldn't have gave given that
kids uh four slices of nutella bread
everywhere maybe maybe 50 grams of sugar
for breakfast yeah that wasn't a good
idea i feel like it was a blessing that
i didn't just like i didn't discover
nutella until like i wasn't oh yeah yeah
mom would pack nutella sandwiches for
lunch and i'm just like how did i not
gain a million [ __ ] pounds yeah
luckily when you're young it's much
easier
young young and asian
metabolism that's like the life hack
right there right exactly i despise that
my mom kept up with like what was
healthy because it just meant that i i
never got to eat anything fun and all
the kids around me always had like
remember the one there's one kid okay
unfortunate he was a bit overweight but
he always had chocolate spread
sandwiches okay i actually that sounds
so [ __ ] cool yeah this man had
literal chocolate bread man i'm out here
eating my [ __ ] cheese sandwich like a
peasant
this man is eating like a king he's
getting chocolate spread with his
chocolate yogurt bro oh my god
when i tried it i thought oh this
doesn't taste good
does it not no chocolate spread doesn't
and like chocolate mousse and all that i
didn't really like that yeah and uh i
think chocolate mousse tastes good
maybe just because it wasn't normalized
for me i i hardly had it so every time i
did have it i'm just like oh i'm having
chocolate for a meal this is uh this is
a life hack right here this is exciting
uh i love cheese strings cheese
strawberries she springs off she's
[ __ ] awesome
even now i enjoy eating the chicken yeah
she's peeling it yeah yeah that's the
thing i i definitely enjoyed this
process
like trying to get it as thin as
possible as well just like like trying
to get like that perfect like it's just
like oh yeah
oh i don't know if they have this do
they have oddly satisfying moments yeah
southeast asia two strings
they don't think they do it's just like
this like it's it's it's it's it's it's
always cheese yeah yeah it's it's it's
in all the imports it's like
supermarkets it's like not real cheese i
don't know how they do i don't know it's
not real cheese but it tastes better
than real cheese in a sense but then it
doesn't but like it's like cheese
flavored plastic it's it's like playing
a mini game to eat cheese and for some
reason that just adds to the flavor i
don't know why
we've never had it
yeah i used to i used to do this thing
when i was little i don't know if i'm
the only one but like i would i wouldn't
like rip it and then immediately eat it
yeah i would kind of rip it and try and
like create a perfect pile of like
perfectly strung up jesus that's like
that's like hannibal
and then i like put it in a row and i'm
like
my name is joseph
i'm 12 years old i live in melbourne
australia
my hobby is
i live a piece of life in the school
cafeteria
making perfectly cut up string cheese
displaying it oh yeah
oh my gosh never had a cheese never had
it you're missing out you're missing the
the flavor is [ __ ] but yeah i feel i
feel if you're an adult and you've never
had string cheese as a kid it's a kind
of a tall hurdle to like getting no
there are some things that i try
nowadays in japan and i'm like i've
never had a japanese childhood but i
feel the childhood in this certain snack
you know what i mean like
like so some of the stuff we tried in
the combini episodes right with uh with
that that [ __ ] crisp thing that was
like that was just like one big whatsit
or whatever my ball oh yeah oh my ball
and i'm just like i've i can feel i can
see myself eating this as a kid oh yeah
they also had like the fish cakes which
was vile they're like oh what the carmel
maybe uh like the fish and cheese or
something oh yeah oh yeah yeah that was
disgusting
yeah yeah i had both of those when i was
a kid so i was like oh yeah
damn damn bro just like just
anything that was like of that size i
would just try to feel yeah like i
realized there are some things that if
you didn't grow up with it uh you
probably wouldn't enjoy it like in time
in in thailand we have this snack called
taro which is like yeah taro which is
basically just dried fish quiet
southeast asians
which is just like
what is it it's just like dried fish
right it's just
yeah yes it's like it's like it's like
because when i think of tower i think of
the purple uh like sweet potato i have
no nothing to associate with
yeah so so i remember like
eating this as a kid and thinking this
tastes amazing and i brought some back
to england and i gave something to my
mates and uh they had they had a bite
and they were like this is just fish
food i'm like this isn't fish food
yeah yeah it's that it's that it's like
i've had that one yeah yeah oh yeah fish
the fish drinks basically fishing like
cheese strings but with fish they took
the
fish
[ __ ] yeah stop making strings out of
everything
i mean i just hear that story and i'm
just like oh
vegemite is over here being like first
time
i never got married
every time every time i like because i
grew up with vegemite as well and every
time i give that to someone who's not an
australian and they're eating they're
like oh this tastes like poison i
thought it would taste good on toast
it's brilliant on its own by the way
it's lovely on toast i mean that's just
the bread coming out i'll just put it on
top
you know what else is actually good at
with is on rice
measurement of rice is actually not bad
because if you think about it it's the
same thing as putting it on time
like the japanese in you but you you
somehow like offended both your
ancestors at the same time yeah
definitely like i i definitely got
disowned the moment i said that on
camera the king just died
i tried it once because i i actually saw
it on japanese uh on japanese youtube
though because they were like okay so my
australian friend brought back this
vegemite thing i had it on toast thought
it was disgusting but then i thought i'm
japanese put that [ __ ] on rice
anything's good on rice tried it and
apparently the the guy said it was good
so i was like all right well if the guy
on the internet said it was good
obviously it must be true they must be
true if a japanese guy said on the
internet it must be even true of the
week says it's good i'll try exactly
that's wow exactly so i tried it and i
was like okay you know what not as good
as on toast but possible possible yeah i
i uh sorry to go back to the gym mm-hmm
to bring it up again um i was in the gym
and uh i was watching an anime to go
along with gym experience is this the
only time you watch anime man you've
been talking about watching anime a lot
recently twice twice
that is a lot you
and then i saw the new season of becky
was out and i was like well this is a
good gym yeah
of course and i watched it and like my
god if you haven't started watching
becky like you need to get i haven't
seen this new season yet is it like it's
this is probably the greatest season of
television i've ever seen
this [ __ ] was so goddamn funny yeah i i
because part three bucky which is the
new season is my favorite pokeball
honestly i've i was like trying to work
out but i just couldn't stop laughing
like just some of the plot points yeah
it honestly puts jojo to shame at the
time yeah yeah stupid the show part
three is when it really starts to get
[ __ ] you don't know what becky is i
don't even know how to explain it it's
men with muscles fighting and it's just
so [ __ ] basically a kid who's like i
want to be the strongest creature on the
planet and then he does everything he
can to be the strongest there's there's
no way we can describe in words what
baki is kind of like it's kind of like
jojo you kind of just have to experience
the reason why that doesn't do as as as
well as joe jokes i think it doesn't
have like an aesthetic that is quite as
appealing as yeah jojo has so much has
so much style and stuff to go around
with it yeah uh but but i think becky is
always more [ __ ] stupid
as one of those like illustrators where
i'm like are you really good at drawing
or are you really [ __ ] so like like i
don't know
there are some scenes where i'm like
damn that's an amazing shot and then
other scenes i'm like i don't think this
man has ever seen a human being in his
life
because that is not how anatomy works
it's like you take a character and
you're like let's make this a muscly
character and you're like what what
proportions do you think is reasonable
reasonable for a muscly character and
then the author just went all right
multiply that by ten and then that's the
that's like the every character every
single character even the weak
characters are like built like bricks
yeah right it's insane and like i could
tell you some plot points and i will and
they won't even spoil it for you because
it won't make any [ __ ] sense right so
at one point during the show the main
protagonist becky uh starts shadow
boxing right that's my favorite [ __ ]
scene is it the mantis so yeah that as
well but so he starts this is it's like
a 10 year old kid and he's like look i'm
going to show you that i'm going to
fight an opponent and so he starts
fighting the air and then he starts
fighting um mike tyson yeah oh this one
this one mike tyson appears out of thin
air and mike tyson isn't there but mike
tyson is landing blows
and then he's fighting him back and then
the kid can see the spirit of mike tyson
and then this just happens
and then he's like and then the main
character is like oh yeah mike tyson's
weak and then he just summons a praying
mantis that beats the [ __ ] out of it but
then he starts fighting the praying
mantis that's imaginary yeah yeah yeah
in a room right like yeah
like some military guys like hey come
fight and then he's like no and then he
just kidnaps george bush and it's like
what's going on what is what is going on
what is going on he's talking about
biscuit oliver right yeah then he
kidnaps in this plot he kidnaps george
bush yeah so he can go to prison yeah
yeah yeah but like so then he can beat
up all the prisoners why would george
bush help you go to prison if if if you
kidnap him they would just doesn't make
any sense i love how bucky just like is
so with the times like you know exactly
when part three was so
watching becky right is like if you only
learned about america through trash
taste yeah yeah it's literally
sure the [ __ ] they they say about it
there's this one [ __ ] uh they i i had
to pause it because i just [ __ ]
laughed my ass off
and uh this is one point where this
american prison guard is about to die
and uh the two japanese guys one of them
saves the japanese guy saves the
american and the other japanese goes why
would you save an american he's never
going to care about you he's american
i just paused it and it was like
what
what does that mean what is it
what is this
in my country why would you save an
american they wouldn't care about you
yes
holy [ __ ]
my fa my favorite barkis and though i'll
never [ __ ] figure and i can't wait
for them to adapt this i think it's part
four uh and it's when uh
barack obama comes out yeah yeah cause
he gets so in the manga he's like
newly elected right so he's like you
know the era of when this was written
and uh like hama yujiro like the main
like the dad guy who's like the most
powerful guy he's like he goes to talk
to obama because of course he can
sit down with any president he wants
like the main antagonist could just sit
down with anyone yeah just because he's
so busy because he's so built it's just
like it's safe but like but like obama
at first is like i've heard of that man
i don't trust him
i don't trust him at all but like i need
to see is he the real deal i need to see
if he's the real deal so then he comes
into the room and he's like show me
you're the real deal
and
yeah and use your and eugero goes all
right bet and he grabs like a handful of
sand
and he crushes it in his hand and turns
it into a diamond moment
i didn't even i didn't even know what
he's gonna do
and then obama's like you are the real
one
shakes hands
so there's like like this show big
muscle if
you're honestly doing yourself at this
point it's so fun
cause like get past the start it can be
a little jank but like the anime is
really good it's really funny because
like i'm surprised that meme culture
just hasn't picked up on bucky memes
right because so much of this is [ __ ]
meme i know right like that's one of the
things
he's so [ __ ] funny so apparently
right because these there's these three
characters becky uh the the uh yuji
rohan yeah and and oliver biscuit the
other guy yeah this is three guys that
are so dangerous and so powerful because
they're muscles right yeah that half of
the the gps in the world is is on it's
in the air
solely to track down it's only the track
them in this world right and so whenever
they run above two kilometers an hour
the gps has to all the gps in the world
has to stop working yeah just to track
these tracks
so and there's a whole section where
they explain that when people are
driving or using their phone the gps
just doesn't work correctly because some
of these characters decided to go for a
light jog
you can't make this [ __ ] up who thought
of this [ __ ]
i'm telling you man
like that's the thing if people if you
thought jojo was ridiculous yeah judges
witches it could be as ridiculous as
barca times and you combine that with
then also another part in another season
where yuji rohanna again the main
antagonist meets muhammad ali
and he's he's like you could you can't
beat me because you took off to do
important human rights things yeah but i
respect you because you did that and
it's like
what is going on is it one of the
antagonists like muhammad ali's son yeah
yeah but even though he's weaker than
him because he went to he he took time
about his career yeah to to argue for
civil rights yeah great we love you but
then
junior is just like cocky yeah and then
he gets like
but then he like but then he like
kidnaps like the main like love
interesting bucky and then gets beaten
up by like five dudes for five days
straight just like over and over and
over there was also obviously i love
where it's like hanayama koda who's like
my favorite [ __ ] character he's like
he he's like bored so he's just like oh
man everyone's weak everyone's [ __ ]
wait no one can stand up to me except
one man humble you juror you know what
i'm gonna go pay him a visit so he goes
and pays him a visit he's just like
walking down the street and he's like so
we're gonna start fighting and he's like
right here like yeah
just in the middle of a crowd but then a
kid comes up and it's like oh my god you
drove i'm a massive fan of you and like
hands them like a shikishi right it's
like can you sign this squishy
[Music]
and you know normally you think he pulls
out a pen does the same no this is a
hammer usually he's built different yeah
what he does is he stabs he gets his
finger he stabs the shikishi and then
slices it into four quarters with his
finger until it's like all broken apart
and the kid's like
oh my god thank you so much and hanayama
card is like man i'd be happier with
that than a signature for me
and i was like what is this thing and
then they start beating the [ __ ] out of
each other it's just like it is insane
like i i'm sure if you don't know
anything about becky that probably sound
makes no sense and it doesn't make it
doesn't make any sense don't winning
contests like yeah i i still don't quite
understand what the story is and i've
watched three seasons yeah i i don't get
the point of course
you watched the netflix season yeah the
netflix seasons aren't even the
beginning of the story because the
netflix seasons are like starting season
two yeah it's like a sequel to an anime
or like the manga that came out like
decades ago
and then it's been going longer yeah
yeah yeah
has gotten a lot better as well in the
season the cgi is kind of jank in the
first season i think but still watch it
it is really i mean i would say like the
animation especially compared to jojo
isn't as good but
like you don't watch it for the
animation you watch it from like the bat
[ __ ] crazy scene it's just like it's
just insane how they decide fights and
it's like imagine if a world was decided
purely by muscle
like
it's like muscles can solve every world
issue in the
guns in this world are meaningless
compared to muscles like guns don't do
anything guns are a suggestion
guns are for normal human beings and
they don't operate in the same world
that the characters do like it's it's
like every single character is an
avengers level threat that's just that's
just what it is right and this is every
single time you think you've met the
strongest character no they he they
introduce some new character that is
even stronger who's the main one in uh
the part three again is it the the
prehistoric guy is it the first human uh
no no no so so i believe they've done
what they did with the first uh season
well it's certainly one season split
into two oh
they've done here so the first arc is
just through the prison yeah yeah and
then the next arc is the prehistoric
yeah the pickle right but this this arc
opens up with um
a press conference from like a safari
where
like all these people died to this giant
mammoth elephant which killed hundreds
of people and and uh animals yeah
and in this press conference he's like
one man killed this this 500
meter tall man well that's what i know
like and then like the press conference
is like no no no it didn't and then it's
like what is this what is this
it's so dumb
[Music]
that's what i love about bucky is that
every character has such as this batshit
crazy backstory yeah that the way they
get introduced with this like [ __ ]
crazy backstory and you have like
speedwagon like
basically a narrator just going over
their entire backs doing all these like
battery crazy things and you think it
can't get crazier until it [ __ ] does
every time i've like almost caught up to
the manga and i'm like how how did they
top the first human ever who ever lived
who beat a [ __ ] tyrannosaurus rex
with his bare hands
even though i know sort of what the next
darks are about yeah this is an arc
about them fighting prehistoric
creatures right yeah yeah
what the [ __ ] they just bring back to
life and they're like let's see if they
stand up to the humans today
like like like jurassic park instead if
they turned in to test the humans
instead of like test seeing what the
dinosaurs could do it's like let's see
what the humans can do against the
dinosaurs because humans are humans are
too boring in this world yeah apparently
because it's just like every you know
no normal martial arts master is good
enough anymore now yeah but it's just so
funny because like the main protagonist
which is the main character's dad it's
just like that [ __ ] insane and also just
hilarious yeah it's just like he's so
insane some of the [ __ ] he says is
actually insane and just the fact
there's a whole whole scene dedicated to
him watching his son having sex
and that was that was what sold me on
the first honestly if
if i can't sell you on becky is that
that there is a scene where he is about
to lose his virginity and his dad comes
in giving him advice yeah in like the
creepiest way uh
the fact that people haven't watched
this is just mind-blowing he literally
squats down next to the bed and says eat
her yeah he's like [ __ ] [ __ ] every day
drunk every day answer your instincts
let your instincts take over become an
animal [ __ ] when you want it and then
top it off bucky turns [ __ ] super
saiyan levels up like powerful after he
loses his virginity
if they have they have like a [ __ ]
because like they actually have sex
and they turn the sex scene into a jojo
fight i swear to god you're just like oh
sex sex is like a battle
i'm gonna be honest though it is in real
life
you're like trying to think of like ten
things at once make sure you do it right
it's not an accurate sex in an anime
change my mind no on top of that right
not only is this the hype is sex seed in
anime immediately after that you don't
need this no [ __ ] goku super saiyan
i'm gonna save the world this man
powered up more than goku ever wishes he
could by losing his virginity they these
people can sense that this man lost his
virginity they did he was he was
fighting oh that's right because one of
the prison guys like tries to come off
no no not one two before this our main
character was so weak that he couldn't
face one of these dudes one-on-one yeah
after sex two of them come in and they
cannot face him
this man's aura this man's nan has
increased so much from busting a nut
that like they can't even think of
facing he somehow developed like hockey
power obviously
it's like gone pre versus
it's like if god turned into his dad
after nothing it's insane like it's this
whole episode was like you had to pause
it and just be like what the [ __ ] is
going on
please watch wacky it is insane it's
amazing i i cannot and this new season
was so goddamn fun i was gonna only
watch like two episodes i've binged it
all in one day oh it's so fun it's it's
insane like i have to watch it if you go
into it with the mindset of this is
gonna be a kind of stupid jojo esque
show i guarantee you will love it yeah
if you can watch with the boys the [ __ ]
is [ __ ] hilarious we need our bucky
out of context kind of compilation just
like get this going just how do we know
zero memes of barking yeah yeah yeah
it's like there are like so many out of
context jojo memes and compilations but
there's nothing for bucky no like how i
don't it's it deserves crimes
like
it's just i could think of so many
there's so many scenes so many clips of
this goddamn show that deserve to be
beat oh my god
oh my lord no but like going back for my
life for backing my god yeah going back
to the gym though it's just like how do
you watch this [ __ ] when you're doing
the gym because like the last thing i
tried watching anime while going to the
gym because i'm just like yeah dubbed
but like do you not get too absorbed
into whatever you're watching because i
can't like i can't concentrate on like
working out so if i'm like absorbed into
a show
audio i want to get absorbed in anything
but running yeah right i want to take my
mind off because the moment i i i want
to be staring at my screen and not at
that calorie counter or distance
treadmill or bike is like perfect i feel
like bike bike is amazing because you
can just if you have something that's
like an hour 30 just go and what like if
you're if you want to watch something
like i will do my best to just be like
i'm going to watch this just on the bike
yeah yeah because you know i to me the
viewing experience is near identical
yeah it's not as good and you're not as
comfortable i'm not going to see them
it's the same thing but yeah you know if
it's something that you don't care about
too much you know it's not that one film
you've been waiting for yeah just
do on the bike of the treadmill yeah
yeah because like every time i've
watched something while trying to work
out because i remember i i uh when when
i still went to the gym
i was always watching youtube yeah
you're watching youtube videos and stuff
i think i feel like youtube is fine but
like with anime i tried watching like
the new season of my hero academia i
used to do watch that yeah yeah and i
realized i would watch an episode and
then i would not retain anything that
happened within that episode i don't
know watch the next episode and i would
like
i'd be so confused as to what was going
on
i'll watch it dubbed oh okay yeah okay
see i can normally follow along and i
mean because i mean you know when you're
doing your you're working out right yeah
you're working out for you're doing the
the sets for like what a minute minute
and a half two minutes yeah someone's
gonna call me you're doing it all wrong
what the [ __ ] but like you know you get
you get on and off time so i normally
just i have it down below
like on the floor so i do my through my
reps and i just kind of watch like one
minute and then american next rep and
then so that kind of get a balance i
can't do that like yeah if i'm doing
reps like i need to be like fully
concentrated yeah i need like like two
years it is really hard to [ __ ] focus
when they're telling me about this gps
[ __ ] just like laughing too much to
do this
bucky would be [ __ ] impossible to
watch in the gym
they're all they're the most muscular
men on earth talking about like the
insane amount of strength and muscles
they have that's my goal right now
doing a squat while someone is talking
about how they gain their muscles and
becky is like the most like pump thing
on earth dude like you can't not go for
the extra rep you know what that's right
it's insane
i don't know but
i i it is it is kind of difficult i you
kind of have to pick and choose
now in my head i have like media for the
gym i'm like this is gym media this is
stuff that i can watch in the gym
because i don't care too much about it
but i want to watch it right right and
if i if i care a lot
i'll stop watching it after one episode
and save it yeah i know i like it yeah
um and i'll save it when i want to watch
it if not the secret to getting connor
to watch anime going to the gym
basically basically get me to do
something like make him lift heavy
things
make me not watch
but obviously right now i've i've not
been watching anything at all because
i've been just watching league of
legends but yes
i'm very tired today yeah i had four
hours of sleep because i've been
watching league of legends yeah really
good this year sounds like your guys
problem yeah i would talk about it but
i i know joey's not interested
it's been amazing
basically it's been one of the most
hyped years in the group stage i feel
like i hear that every time
every year it's like this one
is probably the only esport i try to
keep up with at least for the worlds um
it is really entertaining and uh i'm
sure it is if i i'm sure if i like
understood the rules i i think i'd
really get into it as well because i
like watching esports stuff but what i
actually enjoy about worlds specifically
worlds is that you get i get the same
feeling from worlds as i get watching
like say the world cup or something
right where like even even in the
smaller stages you have like really
small regions and you have like regions
that are like across the world and even
though you have like certain countries
in certain regions that are stronger
than others like it's it still feels
like a global event where you see fans
from all over the world especially when
we had a crowd you know just like
cheering for even like teams that are
not so well known that are like
up-and-coming regions and i really like
i love that in sporting events when it's
when it's not just like one kind of
country but it's like a global kind of
event well but that's what i mean right
it's like i feel like league for me
would be like any other sport that i
just don't know the rules of like yeah i
feel like once you teach me the rules of
like what's going on like how you know
what's a good play what's the problem is
you need to learn how to play league
yeah yeah right but i don't want to do
that yeah
yeah it's like you know it's it's like
again like learning any sport right it's
like it once you know the rules i think
it you can have a really fun time of
just watching it because watching and
playing is totally different yeah
because that that's the reason i got
into league of
i i lege trying to get into the
overwatch esports scene [ __ ] me and oh
my god like the game aside which i don't
think is as good of a spectator sport as
say league or something like i remember
uh i went to an event with uh with our
mates and i found out that you know they
had teams from like different cities
from across the world right yeah it's
really upset yeah yeah yeah and they
were like oh my god they have a team
from london i can't remember what the
exact name was spitfire london spitfire
they had a team from london spitfire i
was like great we've got some
representation for the uk and london and
i remember the team walks out and
everyone is korean and i'm just like
why would you lie to me like this why
would you lie to me i'm really confused
i didn't understand it but it's like a
franchise model right it's kind of like
you know like football teams where yeah
yeah you sell the slot to whoever does
it but
they have so i guess there was no
londoner who was good that wasn't
not a single londoner to my knowledge
the way that overwatch had done it is
that they had these team names decided
yeah that you could buy in and you would
give i don't know if you could choose it
but yeah it kind of ruined it because
you know as much as you know i'm you
know league of legends has so many
you're allowed to bring in foreign
imports yeah um but there's like a
maximum cap to how many people you can
import from other countries right you
know if you're rooting for europe yeah
you'd like to see europe people yeah
yeah it's like
it's like the japanese rugby team at one
point where there were less japanese
plays than there were actually
there was a japanese team that qualified
for the main event and that's the first
time the first time i ever happened in
history because no one in japan gives a
[ __ ] about league of legends so this
like really small [ __ ] team qualified
for the main event and i'm just like
[ __ ] this is the anime plot line
right here what the [ __ ] why am i
watching anime i think it's got a strong
niche here but it just struggles because
there's not a big pc culture here no no
unfortunately and i i don't really see a
pc culture taking off it's
i don't think it's like dedicated to
games like lee yeah i think it's just
mobile gaming is just too massive here
it is yeah um for like people because as
we said people don't have time but like
stuff like apex is blowing up so i think
that's been a real big push for pc i
think apex is like v-tubers so yeah
that's like
well yeah apex is doing very well and v
tubers only just especially at least in
japan very much pushed it yeah i think
because i think before that like the
biggest pc game we had here was like pub
g [ __ ] oh yeah yeah but and like that
was like the best in the dirt and i
think that was like the biggest it had
ever gotten in japan in terms of like a
pc game well pc like bangs are popping
up a bit in japan they are uh pc cafe
gaming cafes
because we had them in london but there
was one um and it was so goddamn
expensive yeah yeah it was like 15 an
hour what yeah and it was it's like
it's i understand that you know you're a
business you've got to make money and
london real estate isn't cheap yeah but
also you know that it has to come up
maybe a reasonable amount i've got a pc
at home
come on like five bucks an hour i'll buy
food i promise i'll buy food you know
you know i i don't yeah yeah yeah it
seems like a bit of a rip it's a bit too
much because yeah if i want to have a
full gaming session with the boys in the
cafe yeah i spent like a hundred bucks
yeah right yeah and bro i can if i want
to play like what about the entire steam
library for that yeah what if i want to
play like a game of like civ 2 which is
like 12 hours
of rip then yeah that's like 300 per
game it's like what the [ __ ] yeah i
think in countries like korea it's a lot
more affordable because they rely more
on like you buying food and drinks and
stuff which i would prefer i'll buy food
and drink if yeah exactly
because i feel like in the uk it's like
it's it's a it's a strange concept you
know it is yeah in korea it's just a
normal way to socialize yeah well yeah i
noticed that in korea it was at north
korea in the uk uh it was either uh
chinese students who were there all day
yeah it was kind of like uh british
people who would be like oh play pc for
an hour
gaming outside the house
what's all this switch it's like the
switch on mario
unless you're a rich foreign student i
don't know if you should be there all
day exactly
so
really because i would i'd love to game
in a pcb that's that's why that's why we
want to go to korea yeah i mean
we've been saying this before
but we've always just wanted to spend
like 12 hours a day gaming in a that's
my idea of vacation
sounds like an amazing vacation to me
turn off my phone just game yeah look at
me just game just get some toxic gaming
in there yeah because i i realized how
like small
like how unpopular pc gaming was in
japan when i actually joined the
japanese league of legends servers and i
was just and i was just like great join
a japanese league of legend servers
perfect way to practice my japanese and
game at the same time yeah a little did
i realize until like about like 50 games
in no one on the japanese league of
legend server speaks japanese no it's
all chinese everyone speaks chinese or
english right because no one japanese is
playing with the japanese servers every
it's just like chinese chinese people
smurfing on the chinese people just go
to like have fun yeah
and what i realized is that it's the
most toxic server in the world that i've
been to
that's because no one japanese is like
yeah
it's so it's all smurfs from other
countries just like
just like being toxic on the server
um so yeah i can see why japanese like
especially with league at least why it
wasn't so popular in japan
apex is a different deal but uh
basically the secret to getting a game
popular in japan i guess it's just to
appeal to v2 right just put some gotcha
in him
put some gotcha in league and you're all
good you've got the japanese market hell
yeah yeah it's a good social game as
well it's very easy to hop in and just
play a few games
if you ever guys want to yeah one day
one i saw you playing minecraft the
other day now yeah exactly yeah i'm i'm
so disappointed you start without me
what do you mean i was invited you guys
didn't ask me come on south december
i saw you dying in the lava like five
times listen we don't talk about it yeah
yeah we'll play minecraft yeah i gotta
get myself situated first because i've
recently just moved as well it was uh
when he places good it was an
interesting uh moving experience mostly
because
of all the [ __ ] that uh sydney has built
up over the years
[Laughter]
okay so we hired the same moving company
right so
uh so there's this main guy and he knows
that we're youtubers because he moved uh
he moved all the trash all the trash day
stuff right um i don't think he was
prepared
like he knew that we were anime fans
right but i don't think he was prepared
for some of the stuff that sydney had
like just within her closet yeah and
i remember so poor man yeah before
before
so before before they do the move they
also have to like scout the place just
to see what they have to move and how
many trucks they have to rent out and
sydney sydney was just like you know
what i know the stuff i i know my room's
a bit of a bit of a nuclear like
wasteland right now you know i'm gonna
clean it up a bit right so what she does
is she uh takes off all like the lewd
posters off the wall right she's like
i'm gonna i'm cleaning up my room right
no she's not gonna notice cleaning up
clear cleaning up my room so she takes
off all the loot posters thinking she's
got her job done i've got nothing to
worry about
what she forgets
right is there's no posters on the wall
but there's just a massive pile of sex
toys in the corner
that she just somehow forgot about
you you really know how numb she is to
that kind of [ __ ] now right it's like oh
yeah there's nothing wrong with that
right
it's the [ __ ] of the round fine art
right there and it's the 10 kilogram
boobs that are just uh lying on the
floor nothing so she forgets to hide
that but she takes soft the slightly
lewd posters off the wall
this is distasteful now so the guy opens
the door and is greeted by just the 10
kilogram boobs that are just sitting on
her desk
that she somehow just forgot about
absolutely
he probably wanted to like get out of
there
yeah and uh yeah so
after we get everything packed up
obviously he like they they hired
different people uh so he's seen all
this before but obviously his employees
haven't seen this right oh no and uh so
they have to they have to pack
everything up right and um so
uh how it was they packed everything up
there were about like four men just
loading loading stuff into the two
trucks that we had uh sydney stayed
behind
um sydney stayed behind to clean up the
place after we'd all we were all driving
to our new place to unpack everything um
and i sat with them in one of the vans
and i sat with them with two of them and
two of them weren't the main guys they
were just one of their employees yeah
and it was just like it was like a good
15 20 minutes of silence right
and uh we were just driving along and
each and the guy next to me just goes
so interesting stuff you got there
and i'm just like i'm just like oh oh oh
my god and i know so it's like i'm
starting to [ __ ] explain this [ __ ]
right so it's like you know this is just
you know we're youtubers and uh the room
that that room that room you know that
room that's that's not my room how do
you explain that [ __ ] though that's like
trying to explain what b board is on
4chan right it's like uh yeah so there's
a lot of [ __ ] up [ __ ] here but don't
worry about it it's completely fine like
yeah yeah you get used to it when i
showed them all the [ __ ] cosplays i
had they were like what the [ __ ]
why do you have so many costumes why is
there so many dresses i don't know
that's my job
what can i say you know i just like this
well what's worse to say if it's your
job or if it's your hobby
the guy walked in my room was like yes
you're single huh
i'm glad cindy was there because
if if it was just me sorting this out i
can't how do i explain that how the [ __ ]
do i explain that so yeah i live i live
with a fiancee she uh collects uh sex
toys and reviews them on our youtube
channel and they're just like yeah sure
review sure yeah sure sure
it's not even the worst part because
after after i have this like uh half an
hour explanation uh explain to them what
we did and just you know just just
explain in the situation so they
understand so we get to the house and uh
so they start unloading stuff you know
first goes the bed and then all like the
other boxes and then the big stuff and
then i had scheduled the gas guy to come
on the same day because you know we've
got a ton of gas maximize you know min
maxing min maxing moving yep um so i get
a phone call from the gas guy as every
as everyone's coming in
um packing unloading all the stuff into
the house i'm like oh i'm about to come
over is that cool and i'm like great
perfect i'm here right now just come
right in
um so he comes in checks the gas thing
turns it on
does the check everything's perfect and
as he's as he's about to walk down the
stairs guess what pops up it's the 10
kilogram boobs right in front of him
that the guy just like [ __ ] presents
with him on a silver platter and the guy
wait wasn't it
wasn't it inside of like a box or
anything like that yeah it was it was
inside a box the box the packaging which
is just an anime girl with her breasts
out right because this thing the this
thing doesn't need to go in a box it is
its own box it's it's just boobs that is
10 kilograms the box is big enough by
itself so he just he stops they both
stop the gas guy looks at him uh looks
at him
looks down at the box
looks at me and he goes
oh very important
[Laughter]
what if the guy was like i got one of
those
yeah i just phoned sydney up uh
afterwards i'm just like why did why did
you give me this job i should be doing
the cleaning up you should be the one
handing it
really necessary to keep
yeah
it needs to also didn't need to go in
the box that had all the loot [ __ ] in
front of it like you couldn't have just
put in like the moving box
we let the movers pack a lot because
what i did with all my loot [ __ ] is that
i packed it in a box separately before
the moving people came so they had no
idea of all the curse [ __ ] i have in my
house
i try to pack as much stuff as i could
but there's too much stuff yeah i just
cause when they pack stuff i just lost
track of everything i was like i don't
know which box everything's in yeah i
try to like i try to like help them and
like try to keep track of everything and
then like about two hours in you realize
i don't know where anything is anymore
yeah and so like even like a month after
i was like which box is that one
specific thing i need him i tear up in
all the boxes can't find it i'm like
well i'm [ __ ] yeah yeah like i still
haven't found my wireless headphones uh
which is somewhere in one of the boxes
um i i like you forget about the little
items that you kind of need in
day-to-day life
um until you're staring at about 20
boxes in front of you and you've
realized that oh this this one thing is
in one of these boxes i guess how does
that happen every time i swear like it
doesn't matter who i ask how far they're
moving how much stuff they have every
move
items just like go into like some donnie
darko [ __ ] happens where it just like
disappears into a void on the way it's
like because like you you look at it
because i had that as well where i was
like okay i'm missing like two or three
items at least yeah i went back to the
old house obviously not there ring up
the moving company they say they don't
have it i'm like well then where the
[ __ ] did it go you're not going to tell
me it's in one of these boxes
because you open it all up and it's
still not there yeah yeah i'm like what
did i do with it where did it go man i
miss moving as a student you just had
like two suitcases yeah yeah exactly
right like you just chuck everything
away you don't need because the thing is
when you're moving when you have like an
apartment and stuff you just forget how
much [ __ ] just is hidden yeah so so you
probably
such a nightmare yeah you packed the big
[ __ ] and you're like oh i'm like 80 done
then somehow you add another three hours
of packing on top of that because
there's so just so much [ __ ] that's just
accumulated
randomly i was surprised how much [ __ ]
was in my kitchen yeah yeah yeah i
thought my kitchen was like two two
boxes three boxes yeah yeah it was like
15 boxes just kitchen [ __ ] like how how
is this
what
why do i own so many spoons and plates
what is this
i didn't know i owned that much [ __ ]
yeah why do i have like four different
types of plates i don't know i only use
one it's because you like go deep into
like covers that you open like once
every like a couple of months and it's
like oh okay i didn't realize i had
17 bottles of [ __ ] dishwashing liquid
just like sitting back there yeah yeah
oh dude man getting rid of all the
cardboard after moving was don't don't
talk to me about that i don't talk to
you about 19 000 i i probably had a
japanese forest worth of cardboard in my
apartment at one point luckily the
service we ordered they took all the
cardboard with them because they
unpacked it all for us
but doesn't that doesn't that service
cost like 10 grand yeah but we were
sponsored yeah i know yeah yeah wow nice
nice for some nice for some i just
haven't
i just can't in good faith pay 10 grand
for them to move my stuff oh no if i
didn't get sponsored by it i wouldn't
pay for it i just yeah like the one that
they charged me like two i think two
grand yeah which i was like oh
okay yeah okay that makes sense i guess
it's a full day of work it's a full tank
it's a truck you're like talking to
yourself out of it two days of work
you're throwing away stuff too yeah that
makes sense
okay it makes it somewhere
somewhere you know
they're gonna make a profit man this guy
you know
um yes i saw your moving company someone
was moving into my building and it was
like the whole place had been like taken
over by them there was like 15 of them
yeah yeah like like the the elevator and
like the outside is like
no wonder they cost like 10 grand they
they've got the whole dark goddamn
japanese workforce here doing their
stuff
they really they really are like i don't
know why i guess they're really prideful
of their company or something but like
they love plastering their logo
all over the [ __ ] i mean it works it
seemed like a [ __ ] yeah it seemed
like a military operation yeah so it's
like that scene from the anime where
they called the sdf they're like oh [ __ ]
you know
get the sdf down here man this the [ __ ]
this is
i understand man if you've got a family
you've got kids and [ __ ] and you're
doing pretty well for yourself i get it
i [ __ ] trying to move with my kids like
i would like i would not want to be in
my situation that i was in plus kids
yeah yeah i understand that it's like
yeah just bring in the [ __ ] sas bring
in the marines yeah yeah
bring in john cena to do it like i i i
do not want to or or especially if you
were you know like you know in your 60s
70s oh god yeah
he's like yeah just [ __ ] daughter
because i guess as you get older you
know you won't be moving nearly as often
you know i still don't know if i'm going
to move in two years four years you know
but once i'm like 40. i'm probably going
to be staying there for a good amount of
time yeah exactly
wow that is a late time to settle down
yeah brian's setting anytime soon are
you kidding me i know i i get you unless
i become a billionaire hedge fund man
then i'll just buy 15 properties and
live in whichever wherever sweet i want
to
maybe fly
one day these stocks are going to turn
green and i tell you man i tell you
you can't settle down if you're settled
in five different countries at the same
time
the grain big brain
because i i'm still going through that
phase where i'm like i'm in my 30s now i
should probably think about where i want
to settle down but
that just like that just like terrifies
me i feel like settling down is when
you're
you you know when you're stopped when
you're working in a place that you feel
like it's gonna be your end home i don't
think i'm gonna live in japan forever no
um i can't speak the goddamn language
and even if i did i'm like would i want
to raise a kid here probably not yeah um
so i don't know
yeah there's like a lot of there's a lot
of different factors that go into like
my long-term settlement like where i
would want to settle down like i do like
asian culture and you know
i i do like live in japan but a big
thing about asia is that i don't want my
kids to go to school here because my god
they put so much pressure on exams and
schooling here that i'm just like this
is this is too much this is too much i
remember i saw a post that was on
facebook you know japan per capita has
like the least exams of any country and
it was like before high school yeah and
i was like i was like oh that's great
yeah so just let them be happy until age
12 and then just [ __ ] them together
they're really happy and it's like give
them heaven for about 12 years and then
give them hell for the next three
that makes so much sense because
japanese kids are like so [ __ ] cute
like whenever you see school kids
they're so nice say hello you know they
they just they're just so inquisitive
and everything and then like you they
suck suddenly it's like it's before they
learn right it's just like a flip but i
swear like every japanese teenager goes
to the same moody teenager face oh yeah
like it's it's like there is no
exception
i'm telling you kids get cocky when they
learn racism
as it is right it's like
it's just like because i can tell like
because you know sometimes with japanese
kids right
just from looking at them you don't know
how old these some of these kids are
like there are some like 10 year olds
that look 30 and there are some 30 year
olds that look 10. yeah you know so and
but like you can always tell though when
it's like a middle school japanese kid
and a high school japanese kid not from
their looks but from their attitude how
happy they are yeah how happy they are
yeah and just from their attitude
towards how i guess they like talk to
foreigners i guess in a sense like yeah
high school students are very scared of
talking yeah they are but middle school
and like elementary school japanese kids
love talking to people
trying to coach children in the street
yeah yeah i'm not going around going
like hello to every child but yeah in my
older shoes in my old apartment the only
people who would ever like converse with
me are like the little kids yeah
whenever i get stuck in the lift and i'm
like oh what floor do you want to go to
where did you come from what are you
doing i'm just like oh what is going on
they love talking to and then it's some
i don't know what happens something in
high school happens where they just
suddenly become paranoid of foreign
they ruin their life yeah yes yeah and
then with the the expectations but you
also know but you also know which high
school student dropped out because
they're very happy yeah yeah they're
like oh yeah hello how are you yes i'm
not in school anymore doing really good
for myself thank you very much don't
have to go through 17 exams a year i
just wouldn't want my kid going through
the system yeah yeah same yeah also if
japanese banks are like this god knows
god knows what the rules are like with
japanese schools
oh my lord i think it depends like being
a parent having to deal with it it's
like i think i think though it depends
heavily on the school that you go to
like obviously like i think public
schools definitely have it the worst i
think yeah that's the same with any
country out there uh but you know if you
go to like if you take your kids like a
private school or even an international
school like i think it gets a little bit
better yeah probably
oh
i don't plan on having kids any time
soon no me neither that's that's that's
a problem for like future me to figure
out yeah that's that's a trash taste
episode 5000 i think yeah yeah yeah
definitely
episode 5 000. terry's kid [ __ ] himself
in school
am i right
can you relate
so i went fishing this weekend i know i
know we were talking about a trash chase
fishing special i'm sorry guys i can't
believe you'd do that too
where the [ __ ] was my invite ask me lynn
maylin was one who invited me mainly
what the [ __ ] i play i blame
i i trusted you meline
yeah melin just uh invited us uh me and
sydney if uh we wanted to have like a
kind of kind of like a double date where
uh we go fishing together and uh i've
really [ __ ] enjoyed it i look like
you're enjoying it like you're about to
[ __ ]
[Music]
so this is the first time where i went
sea fishing so it wasn't like it wasn't
uh fishing in a river or a lake which
i've done before
before uh so
so it is it is an entirely different
experience right mostly because
i've never been seasick in my life right
and we were talking about this so on on
the journey up there everyone's like oh
does anyone here get seasick which is
if you get seasick and you're about to
go fishing on the sea probably a bad
idea
yeah yeah but none of us had ever been
seasick before so we're like great
fishing on a c easy um what we didn't
realize is what what i didn't realize is
that
when you're actively doing doing things
and having to concentrate things on top
of being on the sea and being on the
edge of a boat it like amps up your
seasickness to 10. so this is the first
time i'd ever felt queasy on a boat
right
um
but i mean the uh the entire thing was
like aside from having to deal with the
seasickness it was it was pretty damn
fun so what happened is we
uh we went down to yokohama and we went
to the port there
and so we had they we have they have
this package where you basically go out
to sea for about four hours
uh i think it was like yeah about about
four
times yeah decent amount of time and
basically whatever you catch you can
keep and you can do whatever you want
with the fish so back when i went
fishing
in wisconsin we have whatever we call we
could only keep a certain amount but
here you can like keep whatever you want
and you can cook them afterwards as well
um and so yeah so we went out to see um
and i remember at the beginning
so it was me sydney malin and marky
right and
so obviously it was our first time so
the fishman was trying to teach us how
it was done yeah right and within the
first hour maelyn catches two
immediately right and she's she's just
she's just on fire right now she's like
i'm a [ __ ] natural i'm a [ __ ]
natural imagine how smart yeah she was
so [ __ ] smug uh didn't catch anything
for the rest of the trip
it's like karma compilation yeah
and like and like on the opposite side
of things which was sydney and while
melin was like catching her first two
with him now sydney was like struggling
to get like the real down right like
like
the the fisherman was like next to her
for like a full-on hour like explaining
to her then explaining her to her again
yeah and like like here he was like
eagle-eyed on her just trying to make
sure that she was doing everything
correctly because she was not getting
any catches
um and then somehow like after an hour
in she just starts [ __ ] reeling and
fish like it's no business she starts
catching like four or five fish at the
end of it learns the controls
can finally play the game
and then there's maki uh which
poga who's maiden's husband monkey a
poor guy caught i i think i think he
caught like one fish at the end yeah and
so did i actually no actually i caught
like three or four but most of them were
two well that's very different to one
i caught one fish that i could keep and
the rest were just like too small to
even like to even be worth right right
kills babies because stabs them throwing
because because maki unfortunately was
like way too seasick to be able to
function for most of the trip yeah which
is which
which is
which is the thing where melin
melin also was seasick and so aside to
be fair uh but mainland being mainland
was didn't want to admit it because uh
she she uh she was she was like really
silent after about an hour and she was
just sitting down and i was like man
you're right and she was like yep yep
i'm cool i'm just i'm just uh just a
little bit tired a little bit tired uh
she told me afterwards that she just
didn't want to admit she was seasick in
case like me or cindy would be like oh
no little
baby the medicine for seasickness yeah
you can
totally would have done anyway
but as soon as soon as maki mentioned
that he was feeling seasick she turns to
me and sydney was like maki seasick
she's seasick i'm taking care of maki
stay sick
wow
i'm like wow what an awesome
bra
that's a brother and i'm just like i'm
seasick as well you know obviously i'm
i'm not you know it's it's normal to get
seized like the blinking like
you know what hey or what
but it was so funny because uh maki did
uh the marquis first catch right uh he
he um he reeled in two little like super
small fish they were like baby fish
right they were like this big you know
you can't you can't do anything with
them so it's like at this point you just
catch and release everything yeah and it
was the first like baby fish we caught
on the day and this was about two hours
in and so he caught them and i was like
oh look at the little baby fish though
you know we should probably probably
release them so we uh he takes the hook
out and
he starts like he puts them back in the
ocean and they start swimming off and i
swear to god this thing's like this is
like a scene from the simpsons right you
can see them swimming off and sydney in
her little in her little you know you
know you know when sydney is just like
talks about a dog or talks about any
animal she's like go swim little baby
swim swim and then as soon as she
finishes saying that out of nowhere a
seagull appears and just dive bombs the
fish out of the water
and eats it
and the four of us are just
we're just standing there looking at
this [ __ ] atrocity in silence
and we're just like
well [ __ ]
it
the circle of life yeah it's it's it's
the circle of life seagull annihilates
tiny nature has been restored
oh my god oh but it was actually like it
was actually like a really fun
experience how much was it to go out on
the boat it was like about a hundred
dollars so a person per person a person
and you can catch as much fish as you
want and
and afterwards so you go catch the fish
and um
afterwards you uh they have different
services
so off so you can go to an uh izakaya
where they can cook the fish or you can
go to an onsen
and uh so there's this onsen that we
went to which is perfect for like if
you're fishing for four hours it's
surprisingly tight oh yeah it's like way
more fishing on the sea is way more
active than doing lake fishing or uh
river fishing right because you're
you're basting against the current and
you're constantly like it's way more
it's way more active because uh i don't
know what they call it but uh they they
gave you the like this little cage right
so you got the bait which is on the hook
and then next to the bait is this little
cage where you basically stuff in
um stuff in like fish like dead fishes
or whatever
oh is that what it's called yeah okay
okay so
oh that oh that's why it's called a chum
bucket
oh my god it makes so much sense now
channel's like just
meshed up fish yeah so they gave us a
chum bucket i guess i i was i was
struggling to find the worst describe
this [ __ ] thing it's a chum bucket
man discovers spongebob for the first
time
so we we had a chum bucket and so we had
to fill up this cage full of chum and
the the cage itself
would uh attract the fish school with
the smell and the bait itself would like
attract the fish uh to bite on it yeah
unfortunately like the chum would like
disintegrate within like you know within
like a good five five minutes so like
every every every five minutes you'd
have to like put it down
pick it back up put it down pick it back
up
uh
fill it up fill it up again fill up the
uh chamber uh fill up the chum cage with
more chum from your chum buckets and so
it was actually like way more of an
accuracy that's what god's new favorite
word is now we're going to be feeling
we're going to be hearing this a lot
and so it was a way more active
uh it was made way more active than
the other kind of fishing i experienced
so i was actually pretty tired um i was
it was i worked up a good sweat and my
god the onsen afterwards
[Music]
you know you know how you know how after
a hard day's work or how you've done
like you know after a hard day's work
god catches one baby fish damn that was
a hard time
[Applause]
i did catch one fish i caught the
biggest fish of the day oh sydney caught
the most fish but i caught the biggest
fish
which was the tastiest though huh was
yours the taste mine was of course it
was mine of course what fish did you
catch um the tasty one
what type of food you have uh i can't
remember the type of fish i had i
believe it was a sea fish look at that
you remember the type of fish that we
were catching
a tiger
oh that's not the shitty cheap fish
right that's like the
the taste though right yeah that's the
[ __ ] you put in the can that that's like
the cheap like when you go to sushi
places that's like the cheapest one yeah
when you cut it open it's like really
really white with the uh silver outline
right it's like the it's like the blue
with like a little bit of yellow in the
fish i think yeah i'm totally wrong
maybe i'm just [ __ ] well like they do
have like different services where you
can catch different types of fish but
like the good fish that sounds cool
though i'd like to do that yeah the good
things
yeah
special you know oh yeah next time
because
next time because uh you go to this
onsen and while you're in the onsen just
chilling out with the boys or whatever
they're preparing your fish right so
they take your fish and
and so they take take your catch and
they feed it to you uh afterwards which
is like when you
feed it what you said that just made me
i had the immediate image of somebody
coming at me
open your mouth here comes the airplane
which is which is great i mean
what what better what better spice can
you why didn't you catch monkfish in
runescape that is a high level fish
or shark you can't catch it like 15
fishing or something you know it wasn't
high enough level you can't catch you
just leveled up that fish yeah you can
catch different types of fish but the
best fish come out at like 7 00 a.m so
it's like a 7 a.m
when i'm just like it's always you know
what i'd like to try fishing
[Music]
yeah that's that's that's like after you
know five tries or something that's when
you're like dedicated that's one you
have like your own fishing rod and all
that [ __ ] you know
you know you're legit when you've got
your own equipment yeah yeah sure
exactly fishing order is just one of
those
devices that i feel like is such a big
investment just because of how annoying
it is to maintain oh yeah and like that
that [ __ ] breaks so easily also like
when you get like super serious there's
like different rods for different fish
yeah yeah yeah it's like oh my god it's
like
i learned that from tales of horizon i'm
sure i'm you know i'm sure when i'm if
i'm if i'm 50 and i haven't decided the
hobby yet i think as a white person that
is the default hobby i have
yeah i think oh yeah when i get to 50
we'll see that and golf oh like the two
things i'm gonna be like yeah we'll see
if i have a hobby by then i don't know
maybe i will you don't have a hobby now
i can't be streaming
is that that old guy who's like used to
stream runescape a lot
because i'm the one that keems stuff
yeah the one that comes out trying to
[ __ ] cancel he still streams right
i'm pretty sure i think so
yeah so you know there's a future man i
i mean maybe i'm already like low on
energy now there's lots of people who
want me to be i'm sure man you say that
but you stream more than me and joey
combined
i feel like i'm really low on energy but
then you guys always don't stream much
so i don't know maybe i think there's a
difference between low in energy and
can't you know not being [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah right it's like i'm not low on
energy i just can't be [ __ ] yeah maybe
maybe yeah yeah i mean i i can't tell if
i'm like i am low on energy a lot of
times because i have to like who am i
kidding who am i kidding i have to
conserve my energy for trash taste
people think i talk a lot and then no
it's just like i can serve all my all my
like social energy for [ __ ] trash
taste every week and then i like i've
reset every week
takes a lot of time
it's hard work in this in this show
honestly though if i stream then that's
my work done for the day because i can
do it in the night
how do i have energy after i've been
working all day to also stream which is
to me work
sometimes you start streaming and then
you just kind of get energy as you're
streaming it's kind of i get that
sometimes it happens like sometimes i'm
really dreading it's called being an
extrovert
like literally it's like you're getting
you're gaining the energy
yeah you know that you're stifling the
energy from social interaction right
for me it's the opposite like i have a
certain amount of energy and i have to
expel that during the day basically
expel expel
[ __ ] it out
[ __ ] out we have this [ __ ] out of my
energy
no more [ __ ] we promised no more
[ __ ]
this is like gone goes the toilet and
cindy's like are you expelling your
energy honey
during my energy exploration period
how else is the moving stuff going are
you kind of getting settled in is it
dreading yeah it's uh because this is
it's a bit different now because i lived
in an apartment and this one's a house
and uh bougie
i was actually i was actually really
lucky to get this house because the
previous owner has gotten a job
abroad and so he was very desperate to
find a tenant so we got it at like a
[ __ ] amazing price because we were
like when we were looking for other
places we were we were we didn't even
know if we were going to move because i
remember talking to you guys because you
both were moving you wanted bigger
places and i'm like i'm actually really
happy with my place
this was a good size though yeah yeah it
was a good size and i was just like i'm
only going to move if i can find like a
decent enough upgrade and we saw
other places which for the budget that
was set and nothing was really like
nothing really standing out i was just
like whatever maybe we'll just stay for
another year and then this was like the
last house
that uh we looked at because the estate
agent was like yeah we have we have one
more on offer um
that's uh that you might enjoy
yeah yeah we saved the best for last and
uh so we looked at this house and it was
like twice the size of any other place
they'd shown us for the same price yeah
and we're like what the [ __ ]
um there is there is a catch though
which is i don't know what the exact
contract was called but we only have it
for a maximum of two years so that was
the case
so after two years we have to get
ourselves which is if you like get
really settled in you really like well
remember when we were looking for places
for the trash taste office that we one
of the places we were considering i
don't know if we talked about us on
camera but one of the places we were
considering was exactly the same like
yeah the first place we found it was
like this like three-story house that
was like oh yeah this is like looks like
a perfect space but then we found out
that oh yeah yeah yeah
it was like it was owned by an expat who
was overseas now but he was like i'm
coming back in two years so you better
get the [ __ ] out but yeah oh yeah yeah i
do think this one's actually better in
the end i think the studio is definitely
better definitely better in the end but
like initially when we were looking at
new studios that was one that we were
like really happy with good price good
location
so in in the end what what made you move
there was just because the like the
house of the house
the location was amazing the house is
[ __ ] amazing um and i was just like i
i move on average every two years anyway
yeah so like i i'm i'm i'm
let's do it as we just discussed i'm not
one to settle down so i just i like
mixing it up you know yeah i like it i
like getting it
yeah and as annoying as it is like i do
like it but also like two years it's a
long time if you think about it it is
very long so to me at least three two
years is like a [ __ ] long time
especially for youtube something
exciting about upgrading a little bit as
well you're like you know i've been
working hard i just have a little bit of
an upgrade you know yeah i'm giving
myself a pound on the back i mean my new
place like three times more expensive
than my old one but that's because i
didn't know how i was gonna
do financially when i moved here yeah
and i didn't wanna yeah i didn't i mean
yeah when i first moved here i had
[ __ ] the choice yeah you had to you
know i don't want the bedroom i had one
bedroom yeah yeah same here because when
i moved here sydney just didn't have a
career yet so he was like it was i
remember that yeah you're paying
everything a lot of it was on a lot of
it was on me to like well
she you know she she obviously paid for
it as well but uh a lot of it
a lot of it was if arrested on you yeah
if like if sydney falls through and her
youtube career doesn't take off then all
of this is gonna fall on me and that's
why i was like that's what i was
thinking about but now it's a lot more
comfortable we can both share the cost
so we were able to have like a bigger
budget but still not stupidly large
um and yeah we just found a nice really
nice house and then sydney's career took
off and we went stupidly large
in my mind i was like because we were
living so far away well to say where we
live now kind of like are we allowed to
say well
i
it was very far away very far away it
kind of was kind of wasn't i also lived
really far away from the station so i
felt like double damage yeah yeah like
for me i lived literally three minutes
away from this super close so like i was
like five minutes
like i just had like a nice distance
yeah and then i lived like ridiculously
fast yeah
like i didn't you were like halfway
between two stations i remember
yeah yeah and so i had the really
annoying case of just like i'm 50 minute
walk to one station 20 minutes to the
other yeah yeah which like doesn't seem
like a big deal but when you're some
days when you have to go back and forth
multiple times it really [ __ ] felt
dreadful yeah and i just got to the
point where i'm like okay i'm doing well
for myself i'm just going to spend the
extra money just to get somewhere that's
super close and that i can focus more on
work don't have to worry about traveling
like
now i don't have to worry too much about
and before i always had a plan precisely
when i was leaving the house yeah yeah
because i had to get i had to look what
the train was i had to make sure i was
getting the express train because where
we were was so far away that you get an
express train that saved you quite a
significant amount of time and so
normally commutes are about an hour for
me yeah which is quite a long time and
you do have to really like think okay
what am i leaving the house but now now
i can just kind of be like i generally
know what time i need to leave yeah i
kind of like the commute though because
like me currently i'm also like
just like travel distance for me like to
the office for example is like pretty
much the same as it was yeah right it's
not that much different time wise it's
just in a different way i always
complained about it because for me i
definitely valued distance
from like where i was going right a lot
like i really like the commute though
for some reason because it puts my mind
off of work for eventually
i
i liked it until a certain point because
commuting here was fine
commuting back is a [ __ ] nightmare
because like that's i would always dread
it right because commuting i don't mind
staying on the train but when it's like
when you're going back after we finish
filming trash taste
normally like in london it's like the
rush hour is from let's say five o'clock
till seven o'clock right where like the
the [ __ ] tube is packed you're not
getting a seat and you're like a sardine
for some reason the [ __ ] rush hour in
tokyo starts from like four till like 9
30 at night right no no it doesn't it
doesn't end it's just it just doesn't it
goes until midnight yeah yeah so so like
so it's like the commute back was just
like a nightmare i would like dread it
so i would dread the community back
every time so it's it was just
normally if i was in london i would just
wait out the rush hour but in japan
there is no waiting out the rush hour
you just you just got to deal with it
yeah it depends right because like some
like you said you don't mind the commute
that's good i mean very op for you you
can get a much bigger place you have
even much bigger place than me uh
so it's it's kind of like i don't know i
just i hated commuting yeah and to me
i felt like i could spend my time better
and i did want to spend my time
differently like like streaming right
like an extra hour of streaming is a big
difference oh yeah yeah so that would go
like a long way so yeah i think for me
as well it's because like
an hour commute for me now is so much
better than what i first had when i
first moved here because when i first
moved here i lived in a place that was a
25 minute walk to the closest station
you know and it was like way out of
tokyo kind of thing so like you know
commuting into tokyo would be like an
hour and a half two hours which is the
walk don't get me wrong it's fine
walking is not the problem it's walking
in the summer
oh yeah sometimes you know you can't
always be what you'd like you sometimes
you have to carry a bunch of [ __ ] yeah
and that's where it really [ __ ] sucks
i'm so glad that finally i'm able to
[ __ ] wear a sweater right yeah it's
so nice now like
speaking of weather though like
where did autumn go yeah it's just it
just was like here for two days and then
he's like all right see it just turned
into winter it's always like that i'm so
glad that because i can finally wear
some drip right now without dripping
myself
that's [ __ ] disgusting for like the
middle of september it was so gross yeah
i mean like i just like how japan
decided that it was going to be hot
until it wasn't one day and then it just
decided it was it literally was it it
went from 25 to 14 in one day yeah and
and it doesn't look like it's going back
how does that happen
weather japan has four seasons everybody
that's what they tell you
no they don't it has pain for six months
then mild discomfort for two and then
the rest are okay i guess it's kind of
correct it's funny it's kind of right
one biggest thing going back to the
house one biggest thing that i've had to
go to get used to uh living in the house
is uh living on the ground floor now
right oh yeah i've
only lived i've only lived in japan i
mean i've only lived in apartments in
japan before and i was like quite high
up in my old apartment so you know what
you know i could stand next to the
window and uh be pretty confident that
no one was going to see me you know you
know yeah you know
especially you know
when you sleep you sometimes you just
sleep in boxes as a as as
as you do and sometimes sometimes you're
just out of the shower and you don't get
dressed yeah yeah exactly you didn't get
dressed straight away you put on your
boxes or whatever you just walk around
the apartment um and uh i i kind of
realized that you can't do that in
houses so our house has like pretty big
[ __ ] windows right yeah and so i have
a shower put on my boxes and uh so
the bathroom uh or my shower room and my
wardrobe is on different floors right so
finish the shower go up to the go up to
my living room and just you know
chilling you know before i put on some
clothes um go up to go up to my window
to like admire the view
as you do sometimes just admire the
sunshine on the ground floor
admire the pavement
on on the first floor on the first wow
it's a little elevation yeah a little
bit one direction
changes everything yeah because you know
so sometimes when i was on when i was on
the when i was on like the eighth floor
back my own apartment sometimes you just
like to look down breathe in the
sunshine and i thought i'd do the same
routine uh so i was just standing in my
window um and then
uh someone opens there uh someone goes
out to the balcony to put out some
clothes
and uh me and them meet eye contact and
um i i'm totally not used to this
because
back when you're in an apartment i was
used to just being by the window and
nobody could see you because you're too
high up to be seen yeah um and then so
we make eye contact and then they
immediately just
close the closed sliding door again and
then i realize i'm just standing next to
my window with my boxes out and people
can very visibly see me yeah and i'm
like 20 meters away it was this person
they were like across the road so like
ten meters yeah it's like ten meters
away so they had 4k definition
literally caught in 4k my god if it was
maiden and she would like be
she would have seen my nipples and
everything [ __ ] scarred for life
there oh my god fallen right off the
balcony
in shock
are you liking a new place though so far
yeah yeah i'm really liking it
also another thing uh
i had to go back to my house by myself
to pick up some stuff uh pretty late at
night and uh
it's uh it's it's pretty scary to go
back it's it's creepy as [ __ ] to go in
the house and i didn't i didn't realize
that until i went in
because when you're in apartment there
are like lights
like outside of your building yeah right
there there are lights and there are
people living next to you yeah you go in
this house um and it's just pitch black
and you're just by yourself and you're
like you know what i wasn't afraid of
the dark until i experienced this and
i'm so creepy about them empty apartment
pitch black there was something really
weird about it yeah an apartment's like
i can handle an apartment because the
worst thing if you if something happens
if like a [ __ ] murderer is there or a
[ __ ] burglar is there you can scream
and people are people around you i don't
know yeah you have too much confidence
in people yeah i think i think i think
you like your neighbors a little too
much
i don't know maybe it's probably just
like a placebo but
murderers in japan
their apartment yeah i know but i don't
know maybe it's a placebo but it feels
safer it just feels
it i don't know it's like having a night
light you know it feels like it feels
like it's not too far away from your
front door whereas in the house you're
kind of just there by yourself and uh we
we have a detached house as well so
um so it feels like you're just
completely there
isolated whereas in an apartment
you know there there's the apartment
block where there's people outside
sometimes going in and out there's
lights even at night time um so just i
don't know right it just it just feels
like you're a bit more isolated it feels
scarier uh i could see why people get
scared of ghosts now in japan
[Laughter]
because it's [ __ ] creepy as [ __ ] oh
yeah yeah definitely
i don't want to talk about ghosts yeah i
got rinsed from the comments last time
did you actually wait what did you say
oh when i talked about ghosts people
were very angry that i spoke about i was
like
you don't believe him yeah
but then it was one of those that was
another one of those times i was like
damn i wish i could like go write a
[ __ ] script on why i don't believe in
ghosts and why they're stupid new videos
come back
why i don't believe in ghosts yeah there
was a there's a guy who made like uh
he made a follow-up video about us
talking about ghosts basically oh really
yes basically
saying my point but eloquent and
actually and actually explaining
what is this video called is bob what's
his name dark viper a you i think he
watches trash tastes a lot
he's a speed runner right and while he
was speed running games he was just
giving this amazingly amazingly eloquent
explanation as to why people believe in
ghosts and why yeah
generally like a coping thing and
whatnot yeah yeah you know it's stuff
that i normally agree with but it's one
of those things that you can never
change if someone believes in ghosts
you're never going to change their mind
yeah yeah but but it's like but for me
to be like i don't believe in it
sometimes people get offended by that
they're like never experienced it like
even if i did i wouldn't care but the
thing is i've never experienced it but i
still believe in it yeah yeah yeah
because it's i don't know it's it's cool
i understand that it's nice to believe
in but it's just one of those things
that i'm just like maybe i'm just too
boring i don't know to me it just
doesn't make sense i mean to me i
believe it yeah
but that's i didn't believe it until i
experienced something and then i did
believe it so yeah but again i always
think there's a logical explanation for
everything oh no of course of course
yeah i think there's there's always a
an explanation that might be boring
might not be immediately obvious uh that
can explain it well i mean yeah like
every every mystery ever in history you
know that's ever been solved has turned
out to be not magic right it's like yeah
there's always there's always something
behind it yeah yeah there's there's
always there's always something like we
just don't have the capability to
understand certain things and yeah i
guess the people use that argument for
you that's that could mean that we don't
ghost could be real we don't understand
that we're like yeah but everything else
in our world thus far has has proven to
be the case that stuff like that doesn't
tend to be yeah i believe in like the
supernatural or like the paranormal but
i don't believe in 99 percent of the
media that comes out this is like i
guess
that i really despise and this is one
thing that i absolutely hate about and
which really leads me to feel strongly
against it is the whole industry that's
propped up around yeah no no exactly
ghosts uh you know i don't agree with
fortune tellers spirit idioms that stuff
it's so predatory at times yeah that it
makes me just want to like just get rid
of it all just yeah no no one don't
believe in ghosts because if one person
believes in ghosts then there has to be
someone who then gets into believing
into ghosts and then falls down this
whole rabbit hole uh their husband dies
someone comes to them tells me i'll let
you speak to your husband for fifty
dollars
and that's like that's kind of different
that's just people taking advantage of
people who are like very vulnerable and
very just looking for answers and
but i believe there are people out there
who i wouldn't class as vulnerable
but maybe gullible more so oh there's
nothing bad happened to them they're
maybe more likely to believe this kind
of stuff and i suppose you can't argue
that they're not getting what they want
they're paying for some [ __ ] yeah
but that's kind of what in my eyes it's
[ __ ] but that's me by paying well
maybe they'll ask for oh so i have
friends very good friends who go to
fortune tellers and stuff and i just
flat out just do not believe fortune
challenges
i don't believe in that shitty deal i
just you know i think there is um
there are a lot of questions that would
be a raise oh so you know how to read
fortunes then uh why don't why are you
not very fortunate why are you not using
this to your ability yeah why do you not
own about 10 portions of fortune's able
to be changed is this something you know
and and if if not why why is god
bespoke uh bestowed you with this
knowledge yeah the old people and why
are you not using it to your own
advantage i just find that there are so
many
questionable actions
and ultimately it all comes down to the
fact that you're charging money yeah
you're getting paid well um
you're free to believe in whatever the
[ __ ] you want as long as you're not like
extorting people yeah i mean
when you when you add when you add money
into the mix of course it's going to get
[ __ ] messy especially especially if
you try to like monetize this and i
think i think yeah if you want to give
away a fortune for free go ahead yeah
yeah but like you know to like claim
that you have some kind of special power
or something well there's no way to
prove that and yes right now whether you
believe in ghosts or not there is no
tangible proof
for or against for me like i believe i
believe in the supernatural i believe in
supernatural things because to me i
believe that
at the moment there is so much about the
universe and the world that even science
con yeah like i believe that i believe
i'm i'm near certain alien species out
there exist that we have not been able
to you know come across because the
universe is too big but like the whole
concept of modern ghosts and the way
that we understand them i think is
completely incorrect but what is the
concept what is the concept of modern
ghosts like the idea that someone would
die and they're just going to hang
around a place haunting it like what
like are you serious no no that's not
gonna i believe in it no no god no well
but it's also
but it's also because like a lot of like
shintoist belief reveals right on that i
understand that and i kind of want it
that's why i you know it's one of the
it's very tough for me to argue uh again
like i'm not prepared i think we're
going to talk about it yeah yeah no i'm
not eloquent enough go and watch this
video this time
that's great i don't know like i i just
generally am of a scientific mindset uh
that's just absolutely appreciated i'm
most of the time i am generally
favorable towards the sciences
like i don't believe in like [ __ ]
like people who can read like star signs
and meridian lines yeah i'm sure if you
if you presented some kind of paranormal
activity that we had and we really sat
down and we really went through it and
we really started poking holes in it we
could probably you know debunk most
things oh yeah i'm sure and any of the
stuff that is generally when you say
it's unsolvable or nothing to explain
there's generally a massive lack of
information or not enough stuff to but
but that's what i mean right it's like
it's it's a lot like like ufo footage
where it's like yeah i believe in ufos
but i don't believe in 99 of the photos
or videos yeah exactly like a lot of the
the scandalous stuff yeah yeah same with
ghosts but ufos for sure because we know
that they exist but there's there are
tons of unidentified objects we don't
[ __ ] know about it but there are also
a lot of like you know haunted videos
and like paranormal activity like videos
and photos that are just like no matter
how you look at it it's unexplained it's
become such a
and yeah i i think i feel like you just
hate the culture around it right i do i
really don't rather
i never talk about this because i'm just
like yeah i believe in ghosts and i
hardly mention it because it's just like
i believe in it because i've seen it i
don't really like like to talk about it
because it's just it's my experience
right it's just you can't force someone
to believe in
i don't want other people to believe
what like experience would i experience
that's just my experience i think it's
done personally but i'll never be like
you're a stupid person for believing in
it yeah and i'm and i'm not going to be
like how dare you
because
you guys you guys have some form of some
belief in it i would never be like i
think you guys are stupid because you
believe in it i personally to me it
feels dumb yeah the idea of it yeah but
i don't care if anyone else no and i and
i i'm completely fine with people who
don't believe in it because you know it
can't be helped right it's like you
haven't experienced it of course you're
not going to believe in it yeah because
like to me it's like the opposite sense
where yes i completely agree the culture
is very messy it's very very
sensationalized which i hate psychics
are yeah
there's been so many like people who
have debunked people who have monetized
this that how can you not
know that a lot of people are just
predatory but at the same time i do
believe there is a lot of things that
have not been able to explain
with current science and i think it's
even i think i think it's naive to not
think that there is not something more
out there that hasn't been explained yet
because there's so many there's so much
about you know there's so much we don't
understand we we take for granted
because science says science has evolved
and progressed so much that we forget
how much we still do not [ __ ]
understand yeah
about just the united
don't understand st situation and we
don't have the tools to be able to
explain it i i don't think that a
paranormal explanation is the correct
one because you know we didn't know we
didn't know what caused like cholera for
a long time yeah you know i'm sure at
some point they thought it was it was
the devil all right
it's one of those things where it's like
generally when we've come to at least my
belief is that when we we just don't
have the tools or the knowledge of
subsequent fields or physics or math to
understand certain things but also most
of the time it's so [ __ ] minuscule
what happened it doesn't [ __ ] matter
like if your door closed one night and
it was real spooky it's like why would
anyone delve deep into trying to
disprove you your door uncomfortably
closed it's called a draft
there are so many things that are so
not worth explaining oh yeah generally
most of the [ __ ] that is spooky is so
not worth wasting time on trying to
figure out because it's so little
information that we have yeah that's not
worth explaining anyway well that's the
problem
one more thing
i also do want to acknowledge that there
is you know the whole psychic stuff and
and all that i do understand that there
is a market that is pure entertainment
yeah right i could go to a fortune
teller they could tell me a bunch of
nonsense i don't believe a word they
said but it was fun to hear the funny
words that they tell me
i understand that's an angle and i'm
fine with that i like your funny words
magical things magic man thank you for
telling me that i'm going to be wealthy
i appreciate that but i'm i'm also like
going to hear when i've i've i've gone
to a fortune teller before because i
like i like to experience what kind of
generic way they're going to tell me
about my future yeah i love to
understand the way that they're trying
to do it yeah but that's not of a place
of uh
me genuinely believing it but i do think
that it is kind of
a bit
there are a lot of people out there who
really believe in this stuff yeah yeah i
i i almost my mom's one of those people
and i'm like i'm like sometimes my mom
like takes me to a fortune teller and
i'm like mom again my mom again you get
the same [ __ ] spiel every time proven
that you know they say generic things it
can apply to anything it's called
reading cold reading is a technique it's
a psychological technique but that's the
thing i have i almost have an
appreciation for these psychics not so
much in the supernatural sense but more
on the psychological sense of being like
darren brown is more along i'm not he
obviously is not psychic but like just
using the faults of the human yeah yeah
yeah
he uses psychology
and that's like more interesting
that would never claim to be psychic or
yeah nothing like that they understand
that it's a lot more than that because
psychic really undervalues what you're
doing yeah yeah really
magic brain thing yeah like do i but do
i believe in like psychics and people
who can cold read and stuff like that no
do i believe there are people out there
who can maybe sense some supernatural
things yes i do i died really yeah i
don't care
i mean i mean i think it's because again
like god and i have personal experience
of either ourselves or someone we know
this comes from just my understanding
the brain is just so flawed in many ways
and that of course yeah you know there's
been like
uh i i know someone gave an argument
this i saw a comment that was arguing
about this and it was just like if you
can't prove it's what's that what's that
really horrible argument method where
it's like if you can't prove it's
not real
then it then it is real yeah and it's
like no no no no no no you need you the
burden is proving that it's real not
that it isn't well that's that's that's
this is what i i find the most annoying
about arguing the subject is that for
some reason it's on the burden to me to
prove that you don't have magical sixth
sense no prove to me
concretely that you do yeah that's the
same people who say like oh yes proof is
a synonym for true it's like no it's
really not well that's that's the thing
that's
there's no way to prove it right now and
that's why it's we call believing it
but there's there's so many things right
have you watched naruto
there's that he doesn't just say this
[ __ ] it's like
shut the [ __ ] up i'm about to [ __ ]
leave right now okay so like believe it
there's so many like you know i'm trying
to argue a point here joey don't argue a
[ __ ] point here there's just so many
goddamn clips of people you know where
they they go to people who are like yeah
i can talk to the dead or i can feel the
dead and then they show them pictures of
people who aren't dead they're like
hey
this happens so many goddamn times so
it's like at what point are we just
going to be like come on this is just
[ __ ] literally everyone who claims
they can do this somewhere or another
when they put the test they fail like
rarely no one ever passes these tests
why but like most of the time like most
most of the people i've met who have
stories around this it's got nothing to
do with this the sensationalized [ __ ]
you see on tv that's true this is sure
but that's that's what also makes it
very difficult to have a discussion yeah
people have their beliefs they're so
strong in their beliefs that they don't
consider that they could have maybe
experienced something that wasn't there
yeah more often than not they never was
like arguing about someone with their
religion right which is right
you never like it's just it's just a
lose-lose argument because either you
believe in religion or you don't and
it's neither according to the other side
neither is right or wrong yeah yeah
terrible admitting our own faults as
human beings right there's so many like
you know you go to criminal cases
there's so many like uh trials and stuff
where eyewitness testimony has been
given and they swear 100 they have
nothing to lose by lying about this that
they saw something happened that turned
out it didn't happen and that their
memory because memory is so unreliable
and feelings are so unreliable and what
you see is never exactly what you
remember it to be these things we are so
terribly inconsistent as humans that i
find it hard to believe that one person
who experienced sang so
so wildly kind of outer worldly and that
we don't is it out of worldly though i
mean there are big there are there are
bigger [ __ ] mysteries out there
it's case by case sometimes i've heard
stuff where i'm like no and there's some
things i'm like you know that just
sounds like you had an experience that i
wouldn't describe as um like that's like
a ghost thing it's like you just had an
experience yeah that isn't like a ghost
or haunted i think you felt something
and i thought that was a you thing i
don't think that was the world that you
know what i mean i feel like that's you
is
i was in the same room with you at the
exact same time i would not have
experienced the same thing as you right
because it is entirely
a thing that is happening to you it's
it's it's a mental thing that's going on
i don't think it's a thing that's in
this like physical world or this
material world or whatever i think it's
something that if you put two people in
the same room and one of them's having
that kind of experience and they're
feeling things yeah like when you when
you went on that tour or whatever you
know there's like if you go on a tour
and you you know haunted house and why
one person feel things and one by
doesn't i don't think it's a ghost
choosing oh spooky on the god you know
yeah i think it's
you are setting your your mind is
capable you believe that that could
happen you are a person who is
susceptible to feeling that you could be
haunted so you go into a place expecting
maybe i could be haunted i'm open to
this idea something happens you feel
something and then you your mind
is like haunted or well i i i i could
argue the i could argue the complete
opposite right because i would never
yeah but yeah i totally agree no because
like you you arguing the mentality that
they're susceptible to believing in this
thing but right on the opposite side of
on the opposite side of the fence you
are someone who is so adverse to this
idea that you would you're
a similar paranormal theme where in your
head it's just like oh that just
happened yeah that was a bit weird all
right anyway brush it off possibly i i
think that it's
it's really tough because like you said
if it did happen i i would probably just
i would probably think of a logical
conclusion as to why that happened
exactly and more often than not i feel
like i can adequately explain what
happened where other people around me
whether that was a noise or something
that happened i can normally be like
that's what i find this whole like i
guess culture to be interesting about
right is that like we don't know like
both sides don't know and it's the
conversation of the believer versus the
non-believer who is right who the [ __ ]
knows but it's fun to talk about yeah i
think unfortunately there's people who
argue my side more often than not argue
the point that people who believe this
[ __ ] are dumb yeah and so it kind of
makes this really horrible
of course like that that like whole
sensationalized side of things
that's just that's just an image problem
right
it is it is so much of an image problem
because so much of the the media around
the supernatural is like sensationalized
especially
especially like [ __ ] with like halloween
you like
like [ __ ] tv is unfucking watchable
no i agree in halloween because
everything is like ghost specials yeah
that's all [ __ ] that's why even
though i wasn't i wasn't saying like
you're [ __ ] stupid if you believe
this [ __ ]
the last time we spoke about this i got
like the comments people like were
saying to me they were some of them were
like really [ __ ] rude about it they
were like connor's just he just thinks
everyone's stupid if they don't believe
i'm like i didn't say that it's like i
personally i think that stuff to me yeah
is is dumb yeah but i would never be
like you're a dumb person for believing
well i i think the important thing is
that you like people recognize it is a
belief and people have experienced it
sometimes
people can believe different things but
you never want to make them feel like
they've been discredited for feeling the
way they do i think that's why we have
such a tough political climate yeah
because for a long time all these really
uh
extreme beliefs were like oh you're
stupid they're the ones i think that's
the problem as well is that there's
really a difference between people who
have a belief of like this could be true
and then the people who swear that is
true yeah and like like i'm one of those
people together yeah and they get mixed
together and it's like and that's where
like the bad image comes like i'm
definitely one of those people who is
the former where it's like i believe
this could be a possibility and i find
it more fun personally to think of it in
that sense but i'm not going to come out
and say like ghosts are real hundred
percent no cap no no i mean right like
i'm not going to say that like we just
discussed you can't prove ghosts are not
real but you can't prove ghosts of
[ __ ] videos yeah exactly but like i
have more enjoyment i hate the argument
of you can't prove it's not really i
personally have the enjoyment of
thinking you know what there is a
possibility we just don't know and
that's what i find exciting about
believing in this thing yeah
for me for me it's like it's it's less
of just it's less of just like this is a
fun thing for me to believe and it's
more of just like you know everyone's
had different experience i've had like
my own experience as well and i
couldn't i guess like i couldn't
logically explain it and so what
happened was well
at at this moment with my experiences
and what i've seen it's more likely for
me that it exists then it doesn't exist
and am i open to the fact that maybe
what i experienced wasn't real you know
i'm open either way but right now based
on my experience i'm just like yeah i
believe it and that's what i think i
believe
yeah
it's all about whether you're
no cat facts no printer it's all about i
guess like whether you're just like
naturally susceptible to i guess like
believing in things like spirituality
yeah i think that's kind of it
definitely is uh if you didn't grow up
with that side right i feel it's a
little harder yeah it definitely comes i
mean
everyone around me was quite religious
christian or catholic etc etc um i just
i think
my problem probably uh where i started
to grow a disdain towards that stuff is
i just didn't enjoy it when i was
younger like i hated church i hated all
that stuff right
and then you know when you get older and
you discover the internet you're like oh
i can do my own research and then you
start like googling stuff and yeah and
then uh
i don't know i think i was very and then
the four chance scientists come out
shadows
um yeah i i think is entirely reflective
of how i view the world like i
you know i guess what like what's the
[ __ ] meaning of life bro boy what
rogers bro you're going to bring that
out man what is this [ __ ] trash chase
right now okay like why why what are we
what is what is our purpose man what are
we doing rick and morty is too deep to
understand rig
i don't know man it's just like oh you
know the same reason why when i look at
a i look at a fish what's the what's the
fish doing what's the fish's purpose
you know
to get in my stomach that's right
exactly perfect just be [ __ ] eaten by
someone else right yeah so so like you
said he's sitting around being like so
what is the purpose of this so i sit
here and i look at like all these
animals that just there to be eaten or
to survive and i think that in some
senses we're just the same we're not we
don't have some grand purpose to to have
some spiritual experience it's just
we're just here to [ __ ] eat and get on
with our [ __ ] life
if i want to play some goddamn league of
legends for 12 hours a day that the
universe has allowed me because i've
done my duty which is survive and now i
can mentally destroy my life be a league
but you know i think once you've done
once you've survived that's it i believe
i believe they call that a nihilist
the problem is is that now we just have
now now survival is just the rules have
changed man you're used to being a sigma
male man no it's hard they gotta pay
bills [ __ ] man i gotta be single mail
while i pay the bills [ __ ] that single
mail don't pay your bills number one
sigma mail grinds bills pay you
yeah i don't know because that's you
know i i don't really believe there's a
lot of uh a lot of [ __ ] going on in life
i just kind of think that you just kind
of
just find it there you gotta get popped
and you just what you're doing that's
fine
i i wish that i could have some more
enjoyment out of it
i would but that's just not how i feel i
don't know why that's fine man i wonder
what made me feel that way well how do
you guys feel about it is he comfortable
talking about it yeah yeah sure um yeah
i guess like i don't know for me it's
like at least with like the whole ghost
thing for me is like obviously i had
that story out to you guys about my
sister going through you feel like it
reflects your kind of spiritual
yeah i mean i i i believe more i have a
lot more um
respect for spirituality then i do
religion i think i organize religion i
agree
i agree with the podcast we're talking
about this
we don't want to go too deep
oh my god we're we're like take we're
taking on every topic that you shouldn't
be talking about right now
let's talk about right
for me personally it's like again
because i did grow up in uh
yeah i mean like yeah it was like the
whole shintoist belief and you know used
to go to temples all the time and you
know would hear stories about you know
my grandparents like being very you know
shintoist and just believing in again
like that whole spirituality and like
that like i like spirituality yeah yeah
yeah
yeah yeah i like something
you know i can get behind anything that
the general belief is be good and you
will get good yeah you know being nice
to people like like when i was a kid you
know my grandma would tell me like uh
you know like don't throw the rubbish in
the river not because it's bad for the
pollution but because the river god is
going to get angry at you and i'll come
back to bite you in the ass and i'm like
oh [ __ ] well i don't want to anger them
i'll do that right right it might be a
little bit of an ass backwards logic but
you know as a kid like that is i think a
healthy way to like look at a logical
explanation behind anything that's
generally just be a nice person yeah
exactly just give back yeah yeah that's
like because i feel like i'm i want to
do that just myself i don't need some um
kind of uh belief system for me to do
that yeah i just want to be a good
person and do that
i'm not walking around as a 27 year old
going oh [ __ ] i better not anger this
but like at the back of my mind there is
a part where it's you know it builds
like not only respect for surroundings
around you but also just becoming a
better person and it's like you do what
you have to believe in as long as you're
not hurting anyone else believe what you
have to believe in to be a better person
no because uh like my experience was you
know obviously i was raised up to be a
buddhist and everything like that in my
life yeah i mean okay so i was so his
here's a bit more behind that back story
right so i was a monk when i was a kid
yeah write it down write it down
so as i said before i was among two
times my life one time as a kid one time
as an adult uh so the kid thing was
basically doing it so i could like you
know give good karma to my family
because that's just how that's just how
i was great you know i was too gen z i
thought you were about reddit then
funnily enough karma was the concept
that existed before
[Applause]
um so so then i you know so then after
that i went to university grew up and
everything and then i had this i i had
this you know uh spiritual experience uh
with with uh
with with some people and then after
having that experience i kind of just
like
i don't know what the right word or the
right term to like coin this as but i
just kind of realized
that i didn't know what the [ __ ] i
believed right yeah right because
because because i had this experience
that i couldn't explain logically and i
was like an engineer before so i'm just
like everything scientifically
scientific everything can be explained
logically had this experience and then i
kind of realized
[ __ ] what do i believe right and then
then and then at that point i realized
everything that i believed wasn't
because i actually believed it but it
was just because that was what i was
raised to believe so yeah that's that's
one thing that's really difficult
because i mean you have to be raised
so it's kind of hard to get an unbiased
view of like a a religion or a
spirituality because you often have so
much like baggage or kind of backstory
with that kind of thing so yeah it's
often hard to look at it critically yeah
so like that that was like a actually a
huge turning point in my life that like
basically
put my clean uh put me like put me on a
clean slate and i was like okay i'm
going to become a monk now and that was
like that was like the actual point when
i'm like damn i'm going to become a monk
not because my parents told me to but
because i need to like figure this [ __ ]
out yeah myself and figure out is this
what i actually believe or is it or is
it something that was instilled to me as
a kid and so that was like that was like
the big decision maker to be like i'm
gonna start something new in my life i'm
going to like try to
experience this lifestyle not because
not because anyone told me to but
because i chose this i chose to
experience this and whatever comes out
of this experience and what whatever
comes out of these beliefs are my own
and that's why right now i you know so i
became a monk when you were [ __ ]
alone by yourself with your thoughts for
four uh for four weeks or a month two
months uh you have a you have a lot of
time to think about [ __ ] right yeah and
so in these in these like two months
i basically just like had time to rewind
my entire life and basically break down
why i believe the things i do and why
i'm the person i am yeah and
like after becoming a monk and after
having that time to myself and you know
starting you know i already knew about
you know buddhist the british religion
and the buddhist beliefs and the and so
i after that i knew what i believed out
of let's say what the traditional
religion teaches you yeah but i also had
my own beliefs and my own views on top
of that i think that's how it should be
though i think that's you should take
the cause of something like a structure
that you're in like a of a spirit or
whatever you like and then just kind of
add your own like things that you really
want to i mean japan is pretty notorious
for that right right like a myth yeah
religion and it's like yeah this is what
we believe yeah i don't know like the
whole thing with like karma as well like
i i almost in like a scientific way i
think that if you know if if generally
if you're a good uh you know you're a
positive impact on on people i think
just it just comes back like yeah every
reaction is
do i believe there's this cosmic system
well like like god's keeping track
of someone's keeping dragging like oh
yeah
i'd like to think so yeah
i mean i could just go and do whatever
the [ __ ] i wanted yeah yeah yeah yeah so
it's going to soup kitchen soup kitchen
but do i believe in like in general if
you're a good person that it will come
back 100 yeah of course of course i
truly believe that and like
that's that i guess is the biggest thing
the biggest change before like before me
just being told what to believe and
actually like deciding what i believe
it's like once you decided it or once i
decided it nothing can change my opinion
because i was like i'm so like set in my
beliefs because this is basically
everything that i've built from my
entire experience of life and the only
thing that can change this is new things
i experience because like yeah because
that and to me that's why i guess
nothing really phases me when it comes
like arguing about my beliefs like my
core beliefs because i'm i'm sorry i'm
very set in it
i don't really feel like i have anything
controversial either i'm just kind of
like yeah man it should be good i mean
like you say like you had all this whole
experience but i mean ultimately we came
to the same conclusion right
through our own means right i think
that's what it's about i don't know i i
don't have a problem with how however
you want to do your life just don't yeah
don't be a negative impact yeah yeah
yeah again you're free to believe
whatever the [ __ ] you believe just don't
like hurt or inconvenience others yeah
yeah like what pisses me off is when
people try to put their beliefs on other
people like yeah i have my core beliefs
and i firmly believe them but i would
never try to say hey this is my
experience and you should experience and
believe exactly the same thing as me
because because to me to me you can't
you can't force that upon someone you
know you can you can raise a kid but i
hope my kid goes to the exact same thing
that i went through when they realized
[ __ ] i need to like decide this [ __ ] for
myself yeah i'm sure there's a lot of
people watching this i've never thought
about this deeply and you know for
that's that's not exactly a bad thing
because it's something that i never had
to think about until i had some
experience that forced me to like put
myself in this position to think about
it there's not there's no you can just
go your whole life and you've been
you've been raised to believe a certain
thing yeah and you just never questioned
it yeah that's what i always found quite
like odds because i was always
questioning everything from like the
get-go like anything they told me i was
like no yeah i wanna i don't believe
that
you know which is strange because i
i guess that's why i'm so adverse to
stuff like that because ever since a
young age i can remember i was the
annoying kid who's like no i don't i
don't think that's right
you know but that's just because i i
don't know how i i don't know where i
got that mindset from but i've always
been like that
i guess just some people just don't
really question things because they just
think oh if i just follow what everyone
else believes and if i just follow the
crowd then nothing can go wrong right so
you're telling me i'm a sigma
some people just have never thought that
deeply about it and that's fine well
there's there's a lot of people i've met
with your life dude there's a lot of
people i've met who are just happy yeah
you know they're just kids
and they've they've never like they've
honestly i wish i was more like that
because my god like some people out here
had an existential crisis in the bathtub
yeah yeah
meanwhile members of the church of the
flying spaghetti monster are like we're
[ __ ] happy dude we got there we got a
[ __ ] spaghetti monster on our side
yeah for me for me i just think just
don't try to put your beliefs on other
people try to accept what anyone else
believes even if it's like different
from yours you can believe what the [ __ ]
you want you could like if people
want to hear about your experiences and
give you that opportunity then go ahead
tell your experiences tell your police
but if if if they're not interested
which a lot of people are not going to
be interested then just give them that
don't get offended don't get offended
yeah and don't get offended when they
believe something different as well
they've really understood that whole
aspect of it getting really angry about
other people's
well like being like how dear you don't
believe the same thing i believe that
[ __ ] yeah i never got that either
it just seems very like
i don't know it's like you're very like
like self-concerned about like yeah it's
weird
and [ __ ] like that it's like she's gonna
be able to be comfortable somewhere yeah
i guess if you have a
dietary requirement yeah it's not a big
deal it's like it's like one meal of my
life that we won't be able to eat pork
like i think i think i'll be all right
like i'm not offended yeah
it's fine i'm good
you know and even then it's like it's
you know it's uh it's it's kind of
strange i don't know
it's deep it's deep so we're going a bit
of a lighter topic
where's the poop there's not enough poop
in this episode i just [ __ ] myself
so i've been addicted to like a new type
of video recently
oh i know what you tweeted about yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's like it's like
sometimes sometimes the youtube
algorithm just works in like mysterious
ways right you know what you know what a
story that starts off with that sentence
isn't going to lead to anything yeah so
like
i get this video recommended on my
youtube which is like oh uh
someone sharing cow hooves and like they
get instant relief from bubbles oh my
gosh
yes
i have that section of like videos that
i would never subscribe for but are
pleasantly surprising when i watch them
yeah stuff like restoration
uh cleaning cars yeah um
there was one that was like testing
mouse traps
and this guy worked on a farm and he
just had like every single goddamn mouse
trap on yeah yeah and it was just like
weirdly like like weirdly like kind of
like oh that's cool how the trap works
so i'm watching my style so i kind of
feel bad i feel i feel the same way
about like guys who are in like massive
ant farms and stuff like that oh yeah
that makes me so anxious yeah whole
living it's like damn like a whole
living one [ __ ] one [ __ ] up and like
you're just it just ants everything's
everywhere you burn the house you say i
mean he doesn't have to invite people
over yeah sure i think he gets out of
having to have the friends overwatch
yeah yeah oh yeah i wouldn't invite you
but i've got the end phone
yeah i remember just watching the cowher
videos and i was i've never been i've
never seen something that i've been that
is like disgusting but weirdly relaxing
as well it's it's yes this it's because
that [ __ ] comes off so clean it's it
comes off so clean and just it's kind of
like you know it's it's kind of like
scratching an itch or something like
that you know where she's like see
your videos
yeah just just
seeing the seeing the pus come out of
like the cowl hooves it's like
disgusting but like for some for some
reason when you see the words instant
relief in the title you're just like i'm
happy for the cow man i'm i'm happy at
least
something about instant relief in the
title is just like i feel better now i
feel better for the couch it's
disgusting what you should just do with
cows if we did we're doing this well
they're just like chilling just with
their like disgusting toes yeah they're
just like just you know standing out in
the paddock just chewing grass being
like well i'm in insufferable pain right
now but you know what am i [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah because because like i got
like evolution kind of [ __ ] up there
like my feet don't just collect [ __ ]
yeah i'm unable to clean them yeah
because like these cow hooves are like
[ __ ] hard because what they have to
do used to share them is like razor
sharp and they can like
barely barely get through them so how
the [ __ ] these cows can survive without
humans is just beyond me because i've
seen some of the cow videos put them in
like [ __ ] cages
maybe the reason why like you know when
cows tip over and they can't get up it's
not because they can't get us because
they don't want to [ __ ] they're like
oh
thank god
my feet breathe jesus because like i
imagine it it's just like the worst
ingrown toenail you've ever had but you
don't have anything to cut it yeah and
like i've i've had some pretty bad
ingrown toenails so i feel some kind of
spiritual connection to the cow just
seeing this pus come out right if god
were to make a video like that he put
like instant relief hashtag relatable
say oh [ __ ] if it's relatable yeah i
feel you couch
me using a toilet instantly
satisfying
the 30-minute compilation of using
different bidets
instant relief
hashtag relatable
i went to a restaurant i did want to
vote it down one star because the toilet
had no bidet it was a really nice
restaurant they'd never say i was like
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] gotta go go
to my meal after i just wipe my ass like
an animal disgusting
well maybe they expected you to like
finish the meal first why are we going
back to the day sorry
you said usually
we weren't going to go back to [ __ ]
it's not [ __ ] it's not [ __ ] it's
literally literally one week later it's
not [ __ ] it's bidets and i love them
okay only on trash day spirituality
bidets i want a bidet installed in every
chair in my house why when are we
getting
toto [ __ ] sponsors conan trash tastes
better
oh i want to do that so bad i don't know
it depends you know because some people
like your different strengths and stuff
and some machines can't quite get the
strength yeah exactly also it's like how
accurate is that first is that first
like that first strike yeah right
the water is too cold yeah yeah yeah
yeah you gotta heat up the right deal
anyway that's uh for a future episode of
trash taste i guess that's from trash
taste you know who else likes bidets
though our patrons they wish they could
have total bidets installed in every
house you know one day we might get a
toto trash taste collab of like some
trash taste bidets but you know all
these patrons who believe in their
ghosts
or maybe don't believe well maybe don't
it it doesn't matter
yeah this guy might not believe in
ghosts yeah this might this guy might
you know
you know what next here is fortune
telling tears
i've decided we'll send you a message
how can you do it
can we do it can we do a meridian the
generic one out to everyone can we do a
meridian line to your list of like which
ones are believable which one i'm done
i'm done this is finished all right if
you enjoyed the show make sure to
subscribe to our patreon patreon.com
also follow us on subreddit or send us
your means on the subreddit follow us on
twitter and if you had our face listen
to us on spotify [ __ ] i [ __ ] that up
first time oh my god yeah losing it
alright bye
[Music]
you